Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Hi,
I'm Roxanne Diploma and I want to know who out there is curious about eco sash,
ruff,
the wind's in your hair tree bark.
That's exciting in itself to really let your fingertips and run across the tree
bark and feel it.
Erotic News,
you get a penis out.
Rock,
rock,
rock.
You'd get a penis out.
Ruff,
ruff,
ruff.
Why
Heaven?
I am in photos.
Why are you embarrassed?
Because this is disgusting.
We just narrow your grandsons.
Why are you here?
Because this is
what the fuck is.
He goes that
me.
I'm like,
Oh
man,
the rap rap rap is perfect.
If this was a radio station right now,
I would be like,
we're playing the song again.
I'm everyone and give you guys,
this is so well done.
So Bourbon,
you marry your grandson.
There you go.
Me and my friends,
friend,
summer.
You know who did it?
No,
gaping dad.
What a talent.
Yeah,
that was,
that was uh,
this one.
You can tell there's a lot of of work that went cash.
This is what's called,
what the fuck is eco sex by gaping dad.
Really good job
man.
My friends summer,
which is grammatically incorrect.
It's never me and her real hair on your butt about that.
Because I went to Catholic school and I was taught English by Irish Catholic
nuns and they were sticklers for grammar.
Yeah.
For instance,
when you answer the phone and someone goes,
is Tom there?
You don't go,
uh,
this is him.
This is he.
And you never say me.
And so and so we're going anywhere cause you sound like cookie monster.
It's wrong.
It's grammatically incorrect.
Huh?
I know you say Tom and I and me and a man,
he can me,
me and her.
Yeah.
And that's becoming what's normal now is me and so and so everybody's saying
that people are getting the wrong man.
Before we start,
I want to give a big shout out to my light.
They sent us this,
your mom's house,
a light here,
which is so awesome.
And they also sent us one for Ellis for his room.
And I just want to give them a shout out.
It's my light.com.
Dot.
A U,
they're an Australian company.
So if you order one of these lights,
uh,
just get an adapter on Amazon.
It was like five bucks and now you've got this,
we have this red light and it changes colors and everything.
Um,
they sent it to us.
Mine.
Okay.
I think in November,
I think,
cause we just collect Amazon boxes in our entryway.
And then this one more like,
hey,
what's,
what's this one?
And then we open those from you guys.
Well,
and someone had written a light kit on there,
so I thought it was for the studio.
Yeah,
I thought it was like a lighting kit.
So I started on it.
I,
he's like,
I'm must over that.
On accident.
Yeah.
All,
yeah.
Well thank you very much.
It's really cool.
They sent us one for our boy can change colors and search.
Very cool.
Um,
all right.
There's a lot to get into.
Why don't we a do a proper show.
Okay.
It's just like the gays and uh,
here we go.
Let's,
uh,
let's start the show man.
Crap.
Morale.
Oh,
ecstasy.
All of the pathways that are involved in sexual pleasure are in fact stimulated
by birthing a baby.
Sure.
And when you can allow yourself to open in the same way that you open to work at
the exact same experience
is possible out of your fucking mind.
Don't bring it in one loving to live
well
to your mom's house.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
what I notice about Gaping Dad's music is that he always does close on a fart
sound is it?
It's called a trademark.
Right.
Because like if the,
in his Wikipedia,
it would say one of his trademarks is ending songs with a long,
far,
yeah.
Yeah.
Which is not uncommon actually.
I believe other artists have also ended on a Fart as well.
Yeah.
Or Yeah.
Maybe other things [inaudible] sexy the jewels like no screw.
Yeah.
It goes,
grew.
I ended on far,
it's a lot of people do that,
I guess as as,
um,
in honor of your mom's house of the predominant theme of our show.
You know,
a lot of,
uh,
producers out there doing their thing and stuff like that.
Yeah.
So this clip I saw when I was looking at birth and clips when I was pregnant
with Ellis.
Yeah.
And this is such fucking bullshit.
I mean,
as far as,
as far as I know,
there's nothing ecstasy are ecstatic about birth.
It's so painful
during birth.
You are,
does that,
did I look like that lady when I was giving birth?
Ellis,
this is a a while.
So you said that you saw this or I saw this and I thought before you have a
child,
you're like,
sure,
that's possible.
And then if you have given birth three,
you're bad.
You're like,
there's no way that that's even remotely possible.
Yeah.
I didn't think,
um,
I dunno.
I never thought this,
what this documentary is about was a thing.
This is eye opening to say the least.
I think,
honestly,
I think what's happening is these ladies are convincing themselves that it's,
you know,
you're,
you're using your brain,
your mind over matter to be like,
this is amazing.
Such a pushback on what is notable pain that they're like,
actually it's pleasurable.
Look at it the right way.
Yeah,
it's like the,
it's,
it's like,
um,
hypnobirthing like where you use your mind to kind of overcome what you're
doing.
Yeah,
but there's,
there's
journey with them
please.
It's super painful.
It is the most intimate and powerful experience a woman can have.
It is a very sensual experience giving birth and stations that are like washing
over here that looks like fun.
I was like,
he's got a spa revolutionary.
It's all relaxing to giving birth,
sensual and sexual nature of birth cannot be denied.
Sure.
The potential is
actual,
let's see.
I think it's Kinda like,
man,
it'd be like if you have a fever and you're like,
it feels good though.
You just keep telling yourself like when you're like,
diarrhea feels pleasurable.
Eating my ass hole.
Right,
so why doesn't that feel good?
You're right and when I wipe it burns.
But in a good way,
it's essential burn.
That's what's happening.
Eat some spicy and you're like hot and then you just try to talk yourself out of
how hot it is.
I can handle it.
I handled it.
Yeah.
Those are just sensations on my tongue.
It's not paying good.
Tastes good.
Take the next bite.
Then you go.
That's what you do.
That's how you eat though or it.
I think these women,
first of all,
for me personally,
there was nothing sexual about giving birth whatsoever.
No,
not,
not a lick.
Especially the part where when contractions begin,
you shit your brains out.
It's like your body's way of,
of cleaning everything out here.
Shooting on the toilet or,
no,
when I went into Labor at home,
I just started shitting.
That's how I knew I was in labor because I'm like,
oh,
I'm having like period cramps and then your body naturally wants to get rid of
everything so that you can push.
I'm assuming it's like nature's Enema,
you know,
so you shit a lot and then,
and then you're just a ton of pain.
Well,
you shit Outta here.
Brown hall and then out your badge all later.
You should have personnel.
Essential experience.
Ever so sensual,
Huh?
Crowning essential.
Kind of go inside myself.
Really try to begin the centering that I would need to have to make it to labor
pain.
Yes.
Right.
Essential oils.
She said,
I'm going to go through this pain.
She didn't say I'm going to cum super hard and enter the world.
She said pain.
Right.
Which is optional.
You don't have to feel that much.
It does hurt even with an epidural,
but you can choose to not suffer.
And this era,
as a quick aside,
we'll be joined shortly by the creator of [inaudible] talk some shit.
Oh my goodness.
One of the most hilarious videos ever on youtube was made by Brent wine,
Bach,
and he'll be here in a little while.
The creator.
I want to talk some shit.
Baby dubs.
Yeah.
Call me.
We're going to get inside of his mind.
It is a straight gift from your video too.
Oh,
awesome.
Yeah.
He's a strange ranger.
Back to coming during birth.
It's not possible.
It's pleasure.
Sure.
[inaudible]
but I think that,
um,
maybe you,
you can trick yourself like that lady who was like,
it was awesome.
I love it.
Thank you.
Which just shows you how powerful the mind is.
Is he coached her into being like,
yes,
it feels good.
That's what it is.
That's what hip no birthing is.
Before I had Ellis,
I went and I got that done.
Where they hypnotize you into reimagining pain and stuff.
Eh,
that doesn't,
it didn't work for me.
Ultimately because this hurts.
This hurts.
It hurts and then you just push through the pain.
But yes,
it is a,
it is a reframing of what's happening.
The doctor and I don't think,
I don't see doctor under your name so that it's possible to cum super hard.
Yeah.
Ecstasy.
All of the pathways that are involved in Sam d pleasure are in fact simulated by
birthing a baby.
And when you can allow yourself to open in the same way that you open to work at
the exact same experience is possible.
Vague.
Well,
but not probable.
I'm guessing.
That's another important footnote.
This bitch has never squeezed a person out of her coach.
She don't know what the fuck she is talking.
I don't think so.
Nah.
Hell No.
That's why she's saying stupid shit like this.
She never fucking give birth.
Oh,
okay.
You're just talking like you're like,
I need my privacy.
Well that's what I'm saying.
What I'm saying when,
oh,
we stroll,
you know what I'm saying?
Does the hospital decades ago we treated it like it was surgery.
They put her in a wheelchair.
She can walk.
She's not sick.
I liked sitting in the wheelchair with birth,
uh,
particularly,
shows like,
er,
people are coming screaming into the Er as though having a baby is the biggest
disaster on earth and dad has imprinted generations of people.
But that goes,
that does speak to the part that it's psychological.
The pain part.
She's saying it's imprinting to you that this is a terrified.
So maybe like your early impressions are,
this is going to be terrifying.
When would they should show you is women walking into the Er like,
Ooh,
I like,
this feels good.
You know what I wish you would've done,
I mean,
I see all these nice guys coaching their wives and rubbing backs.
I mean you were eating a Burrito at the time?
I was in labor,
but like I really wish we could have done it while I was in labor.
Like why didn't that occur to you?
I didn't do it on the no,
you don't do it again.
I have another kid.
Navi,
so sensual.
Oh fuck.
And then the doctor's like,
keep going time.
I mean you're crowning.
What a perfect time to have intercourse.
Let's have sex.
Oh my God.
Um,
oh.
What are you going to do?
Like if I have another baby while I'm giving birth this next time around,
I feel like you should be doing something too.
I'll have another burrito
that would annoy the shit out of me.
By the way.
You see all these like loving hippy husbands that are squeezing on her belly and
massaging her.
I'd be like,
get the fuck away from me.
Do Not fucking touch me.
I'm in so much pain.
You were asking for that.
I would be like,
are you fucking serious?
You're like,
haven't I done enough?
Yeah.
This whole baby making I already noted.
You want from me?
Yeah.
Well,
there is nothing.
Got
someone that's got to be safe.
Kenny Rogers uninterrupted,
and that is how you will have an orgasmic birth.
The man says the fucking Kenny Rogers old ass man.
How does he know anything about it?
I love when men talk about this shit.
Like they know what it's what it's about.
People always talk about what animals are thinking that,
oh
well your dog,
he's nervous about this and he's not sure what will happen next.
I'm like,
oh,
did he tell you that?
How did that come about?
They're like,
yeah,
no,
I I know.
Uh,
your dog right now,
he's,
he's happy about what you did and so you just need to keep doing that and your
dog will stay happy.
Believe animal sidekicks.
I don't believe veterinarians that are like telling me what the dog is thinking.
I understand.
If they're like,
your dog is sick,
the one they're like,
the dog is thinking that you should come home earlier.
I'm like,
uh Huh.
Oh God,
stupid.
Is that what the dog thinks?
Yeah.
All right,
great.
Like you know about fucking dogs.
I agree.
Unless you've been there,
done that.
You can't say shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Whatever.
I've studied dogs.
You don't know what the dog's thinking.
No,
this is like this.
Does it know how hard you're going to come when you have a baby?
And I wouldn't trust a male gynecologist either.
Fuck that shit.
No way,
dude.
I told you about the one in high school and my town's tell the audience so that
they can hear it.
My friends
dad had a party and we,
I was in high school and we all went over there and there was,
you know,
it was a big party at a big house,
gynecologists,
gynecologists and like,
you know,
uh,
a well respected one.
Um,
and so I got him alone for a minute.
I was like,
can I ask you something?
I'm a teenager,
so you know,
obviously I'm hypersexual at the time,
right?
And I go,
hey man,
you're a gynecologist.
I go,
how do you separate,
you know,
of a Jina being,
uh,
stimulating sexually to you versus professional?
How does that happen?
And he goes,
pussies,
pussy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm perverts disgusting.
I looked at him,
I was like,
really?
He's like,
yeah.
Yeah.
It basically,
he's basically saying,
oh,
I bite my tongue,
but I'm still thinking about getting them
been there.
Snatches all day.
Yeah.
I wouldn't,
I mean,
I wouldn't want to touch balls and all day and I don't know what's going on.
You can study dicks and balls,
but until you yourself have a dick and balls,
you don't know what's going on.
You're all just,
she wasn't mine,
but that one I thought,
I thought about that.
I was like,
all you do is look at Dick's all day.
I wanted to ask her a Dick Questions,
but it was at,
it was a kind of an upscale dinner.
I didn't want to be like,
what's like the biggest Dick you've seen?
That's what I wanted to ask her.
Of course.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
I want to know that because I asked my gunny about nasty snatches and she's
like,
yeah.
Oh,
I asked my gynecologist one time about male gynecologist.
She goes,
oh yeah,
they're all Weirdos.
She goes,
I would never,
ever.
She goes,
they're all Weirdos.
Psychos Herbert's start jacking those decks when you're,
do you think that's the big temptation?
Probably when she,
why would this woman of all the fields of medicine,
I know everything that's out there,
internal medicine.
You can be a cardiologist,
you could be a podiatrist,
all of them.
And she's like Dixon Baltics and that's what I'm saying,
you've gotta be messed up in your head.
It's not that weird for me to be like you ever started jacking him there.
We started sucking on them when you're in there.
Yeah.
Like she,
they pulled down their pants and she just starts licking her lips.
Like,
yeah,
it tastes these balls like the pornos when they're like,
what if,
but what if that's her special method and that's why her clients are,
there's just so many patients.
Cause she's like,
well first I have to do a taste test on these balls,
sir.
Would you submit to a taste test?
I don't know.
That guy always has to act like it was like,
I dunno.
I don't know if I'm comfortable with that.
And then shit from across the room.
She goes and she spits on him like,
whoa.
And then as she's like,
I think my nurse is going to have to help me.
I'm going to say another female being serious here.
I'm the nurse.
I'm trying to be serious about this.
I mean I'm too,
I'm being serious.
I,
here's why I think anybody would choose that.
Let's keep it real.
It's because um,
because I think that you choose it because it is a little titillating on some
level it might be a repressed like maybe this girl,
the,
this female urologist was like,
you know,
had a strict upbringing.
They're like,
no boys,
no dates,
no you study.
And then she got the college and then,
then her parents were still like,
you better not be going out and getting the basics you need to get to medical
school.
You can not fuck around.
By the time she got there and they're like,
what fields?
She was like,
Dixon balls.
I'm going to,
Jack is many dicks and balls as I want here.
I'll show you mom.
And also she has control and hour more so than the actual,
she's the one telling them about what their digital should be doing.
Especially on men.
That's their most prized body part is the taken boss.
That's what urologists are
and I think it's a power thing.
Control.
Totally.
Definitely.
Think about that.
All doctors cause you essentially a point you go like you tell me,
am I going to live here?
I could make you feel better.
I can tell you the reality of this situation.
I'm there like a version of God,
you know?
Yeah.
They're telling you like this is what's going to happen.
I will say during my friend to come from me,
right.
During fertility stuff,
like when we conceived Ellis,
I had a two,
I had two male doctors examined me when they give you ultrasounds.
Yeah.
And both were terrible at it.
I had an old ass white guy he beat,
he didn't know where the hole was and he like shoved the other guy,
a younger gentlemen.
He had no fucking clue how to get a spot or the ultrasound and it was like,
dude,
it's so number one,
they don't like that when the females we're seeing if you were dilated.
Yeah.
Checking it.
That one was like jam.
Yeah.
And one of them was like gentle.
That's all in the personality.
I mean the jam when I was like,
Ooh,
why don't you take it easy man,
I,
I could see it.
Oh God.
It's the worst.
Oh Man.
Like,
and it's like glass up there when you're,
when you're really,
really pregnant.
Like your,
it's hormonal and it just feels like someone's putting nurses like high school
time.
Just like,
oh yeah.
Ready?
Super aggressive.
Yeah.
Have you ever had a female,
um,
Dick Doctor?
No.
[inaudible] never had a female.
Really?
I'm trying to think.
No,
no.
Proctology that's one where you go,
Huh?
Why would you choose assholes?
Well,
we need an asshole doctor.
Right.
But to deal with that,
that's fucking gnarly.
Trying to think if I've ever had a female.
I don't think I've had a female doctor.
Well No,
cause I mean general physicians now I've had guys,
um hmm.
No female nurses.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I've never had a male nurse.
Really.
I've had,
I've had male nurses.
Yeah,
I'd stood up.
I've had multiple by the way,
but it still stands out.
I'm on the flight yesterday.
They,
um,
the first officer got on the PA and was like,
uh,
the pilot said that,
um,
we are going to um,
we're going to experience some turbulence and she said to stay in your seats on
Blah,
blah blah.
So they kept referring to the pilot as a sheet,
which you really is more common,
but it's still stands out.
You're like,
Oh,
is it?
Well,
you can't really make assumptions because what if biologically it's a he,
but she feels like a shame.
But then he was using the she pronoun so she might,
she might be comfortable with it,
but to see what you were saying,
maybe a male got their license and then changed.
That's what I'm saying.
He could have woken up a mouse,
a man,
and then by the time the flight took off became mushy.
So Dawkins happening all the time.
Yeah.
Have it all the time.
You got to respect it.
So huge development in the Sigora home.
I,
uh,
I tried to install a tushy on my own,
which was a disaster.
We got sent one for free and I was like,
you think I'm so dumb?
Well,
cause they make it sound like it is there.
Like anybody I know you,
I'm like,
you're not going to be like,
let me install this shirt right now.
So of course I ended up ruining the toilet.
It kept overflowing and running.
So I called the handyman and he installed it.
And now we have two.
We have a Toshi and the total washlet three 50.
He and I have to tell you there are two different toileting experiences.
The total washlet provides a warm spray kind of an all over.
Yeah.
Clean.
Like I like it because it covers the kibbles [inaudible] bits.
That's right.
Now the tushy is expressly for your asshole.
That is like a fire hose.
High pressure.
Should have tried it today just on your butthole.
Ah,
so it's totally different.
It's totally different.
Yeah.
Uh,
both wonderful experiences though.
I recommend either for those of you who are interested in a bad day.
I,
I can't recommend them enough.
But the toasts,
she's like an affordable thing.
It is.
How's my hope now?
Huh?
No,
I didn't get the,
the warm one water Toshi.
Cause like I didn't want to deal with the plumber coming and doing all that or
electrician,
blah,
blah blah.
How was I'm getting that guy over here.
Was that pretty easy though?
Oh my God.
So I find this guy through a friend of friend and any goes,
we're texting back and forth and he goes,
what's your address?
I give him our address and then he goes,
can I have directions?
And I was like this,
that's odd.
But okay,
maybe this person's older.
Yeah.
I don't know how old he is.
And I give him directions and then he goes,
well,
is that come coming from north or South or,
and I'm like,
okay,
coming from this way it's,
and it's essentially three things.
Turn right,
turn right turn right.
Yeah.
From where?
From where he is.
And he keeps texting me and not understanding what I'm teaching and I,
so finally I was like,
whatever dude.
Like I just,
I stopped talking to him cause I'm with the kid alone and I can't handle him.
So the day of he texts me,
is it a ride on the bus street?
He's still confused.
Yeah.
And then he calls,
calls me and I'm like,
you know what?
In my head I go,
I can't do with this.
Listen Bro,
if you can't find my house,
you don't have the job.
You basically make that decision.
Right.
You're a moron.
Well yeah,
cause then I go,
if you can't even find directions to my house,
how are you going to fix my damn toilet?
How are you going to fix the God damn door knob?
I need it.
No,
it
just reminds me of that,
by the way.
This is when people ask to like friends asked to come to a show.
Oh my God,
stop it.
Yeah.
They're like,
Hey,
I saw you're going to,
you know,
you're gonna be in Montreal and I can I get tickets to this show?
Sure.
Okay.
Where do I get the tickets?
I go there,
I will call at the,
at the buck every other venue ever,
ever under the stars.
What time should I arrive before the show?
Yeah.
Where's shows at eight and they like,
oh,
okay.
Parking's there.
I'm like,
I'm sure it is.
I don't know.
I don't live there so I don't know.
And then they're like,
um,
is there someone that I should ask for when I get there?
Do you know if,
if,
um,
if there's parking on site or I'll have to park somewhere else and then get
their Google it.
Um,
where should I meet you after the show?
Do you know if,
um,
do you know where,
where in the venue?
My seats will be and I'm like at the,
at a certain point I do the same thing.
I go,
no,
I'm finding it's in hands and
then I'll get like 10.
And then after the show they're like,
you know what was texting you earlier?
Like I had my phone off.
I didn't even,
I didn't,
I left it,
I don't even know the day of the guys appointment.
Our appointment,
I'm with my son,
I'm alone.
You know toddlers are a handful.
I also don't have access to my phone 24 seven because I'm running around with
the kid.
So he calls me,
leaves me voice mails,
and I'm ignoring him.
At this point,
I'm like,
you know what,
Bro?
If you can't figure that you don't have fucking gps on your fuck,
I know you have a cell phone.
It's all you gotta do is open up Google maps or whatever maps.
He has a cell phone.
So he shows up angry.
He finally finds the house,
he shows up and he's a little like,
I think your phone is off.
And I was like,
Oh,
is it?
Yeah.
Like I lie.
I'm like,
I was with my toddler.
Sorry,
I can't really.
And he and I go,
he goes,
I had a,
I didn't turn right on this or whatever.
He's upset because he couldn't find the street.
And then I go,
well,
don't you have gps?
Oh,
I don't believe in that.
I don't use that.
That's why you're angry.
Right.
Stupid.
So use the technology.
You know why?
Because he's a hippie.
He lives in the mountains and he doesn't use air conditioning.
Yeah.
And I think he's one of these people that thinks that they're watching.
If he's using gps and I wanted to fucking throw my cell phone and it's,
and I was so angry with them,
111 one day last week.
Oh,
and here's the best part.
So we had a couple of other things that he was fixing.
This guy was giving me a fucking tutorial as he was doing it.
Like,
well,
you shoot the toilets all working the flusher in this mechanism here.
And I was like,
bro,
Bro,
motherfucker,
listen one though.
I don't want to,
I don't want to be educated.
That's why I'm paying you the $50.
You fucking do this for me.
And he's talking me through what's,
no,
no.
I don't need to hear any of this.
I'm taking care of my kid like you.
You do it.
That's why I called you asshole,
explaining to me why the door knobs aren't working.
I don't care.
Just fix it please.
I don't want to learn.
I don't.
No,
I'm too old to learn.
Yeah,
I know.
I feel the same way.
Just fix it.
That's fine.
Make it go away.
That's why you're here.
You know,
like I don't need,
he didn't talk to me about how just does it.
Well,
when you go to a dentist,
you don't want them explaining.
This is how I'm I,
I,
this is why you were educated.
This is your specialty.
You do you,
this specialty was coming while you're giving birth,
orgasmic birth.
Oh,
Jesus will change the way you think about childbirth and yourself forever.
If you were told that you could have one in the must,
physically,
emotionally,
spiritually,
transcendent moments,
back,
tattoos to get there,
which you really say no.
Yes,
no,
you wouldn't.
You're lying.
I think.
I wish you'd get a tattoo like that guy.
If I can get it.
Yes,
I will.
I will have a very open mind
if I have another baby.
Bring that lady sexual pleasure.
I'm going to show you.
You know what?
I told my mom yesterday.
She goes,
she was telling me that she farted really big and I go,
hey,
you know you can make 'em,
you can make money.
And I said,
uh,
if you start recording those
people pay for that online.
And she got so disgusted and so upset and she goes,
I would never lower myself to that.
And I go,
why?
It's extra money to go to the casino.
Um,
so here's some like the casino money for you.
And she was like,
ah,
never,
never.
But people are making money.
You know what a square,
it's money left on the table as far as I get her money.
Yeah,
there you go.
I like this new genre,
the farting in public shot,
probably checking different locations.
I think the nice thing about somebody that's into her video as they go,
I can go to that Walmart,
I can go to where she farted and if I must going to do that,
I mean that'd be a pretty cool following developed.
We've reserved fart mistress dotcom and so far we have not put content on there.
Maybe your mother's the Fart.
Maybe we can just put videos of her.
Trying to be talked into doing it and just,
it's really funny.
The reluctant,
the reluctant Fargo stress.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
In the candle aisle,
no less.
I wonder what her preparation is like when she knows she's going to shoot.
It's so interesting.
That's really what the interesting thing about these people that do this is
like,
well,
do you know that you're going to have this for breakfast?
And then you can go shoot your video?
I'd assume so.
Yeah.
If I were to do these videos,
I would eat a lot of dried apricot and Vietnamese food to prepare.
I'd have a bowl of pho and then dried apricots,
but
slippers.
Good one.
Wow.
I love this girl.
Yeah,
she's pretty great.
Now she is monetizing these videos,
right?
This is for sale.
Okay,
good.
Yeah.
Well I'd hate to think of people wasting our precious farts.
Go to her.
Yeah.
I hate not monetizing them.
You know,
there's an audience out there that what them was trying to tell my mother,
can we please do a phone call where you're explaining this to her about the
fire?
Yeah.
Try calling her.
I'm gonna try calling right now.
Let's say if she can understand this.
Okay,
I'll see if I can get,
I'm dying to have to hear her talk about this.
I mean,
good luck getting her fucking answer though.
it didn't really is like,
well let's text her.
It's like calling somebody a fucking a hundred years ago or something.
You know,
like they're like,
what?
What Day will you be calling?
She might as well say to me because it's so annoying.
Both of them are like this now.
I'm like,
I called you a text.
You,
Oh,
I uh,
I left the charging.
I'm like,
Dude,
how often do you leave at charging?
Why do you leave with charging so long?
I texting or Tom's calling you answer your phone.
Hello.
All right,
let me see if I can care about this.
I just want to make a phone call.
All right.
Let's see.
I don't have her number even memorized.
I'm texting her right now,
so
let's see if she'll do it.
Actually,
emails are just pouring in about the moose soup lady too.
She's really struck a chord with our audience and she struck a chord with my
heart.
I've been thinking about her all weekend to Moose suit.
Yeah.
Well mom reason those Zube later
and her o m g Gosh,
I know.
I just love her.
She's fantastic.
Okay.
Oh,
am Jay Jay,
come on over to my exam lane or
o and g.
Calm down and forwarded to automatic voice math later.
Try The house.
None other,
no home.
Oh there.
Oh,
that's right.
They're visiting something.
Yep.
Oh,
she is.
I was meant to be.
Okay.
Hello
mom.
God,
Mommy.
Hey,
I said to the band.
Okay.
I'm in the,
uh,
no,
I'm in the,
I'm in my office.
I have a different phone there.
Hey,
I wanted to ask you real quick.
I did some research.
I found out it's like,
it's pretty serious money you can make if you do some fart videos.
Oh my God.
I'm sitting here and they have to nicer.
But I mean,
would you consider putting up a couple just to test the market?
I was talking about the price of the house.
No,
but I'm saying like I think it can generate extra gambling money for you.
For the casinos,
I think.
I think you're looking at maybe a couple thousand a month.
Okay.
A month.
Yeah.
And all you gotta do is like,
if you feel one coming,
you just make you just hit record from it.
You just hit record on your,
on your iPhone and then send it to me and I'll have,
I'll have direct deposit set up for you.
Oh my God.
People will pay $5 $5 per fart video.
I understand what people are avoiding.
You told me and I prayed to God.
I don't get that wrong.
Okay,
but what is there a number that will make you feel comfortable to start?
I mean,
I just think that this is a great business opportunity.
That's all its money on the table.
3000 a month.
Okay.
I mean,
I'm going to do some research if I can get people to sign up.
Will you start posting videos?
Oh my God.
He said,
absolutely.
Well,
will you?
Will you consider it?
Okay.
I'm going to do some research and see if I can get the,
that type of commitment.
And just so you know,
it might be more so I'm just starting low,
but it might go more than that.
Gosh,
I can't believe I'm getting excited about.
Okay.
And then also if you could,
do you know what can she do for,
hold on.
I know already that some people were asking if,
if you could,
when you do these video,
if you do,
like if you feel one and you record it fart and then go like,
oh my gosh,
I didn't mean to do that.
Do they practice like that?
Okay.
Can you try one for us?
Oh my God.
You have to go like,
oh,
you have to go.
Oh,
I didn't mean to,
Oh my God,
how do I do it?
What do you mean?
You just have to put a cork.
Yeah.
And then you send me the video.
Like you,
you pull your iPhone up,
you pull your iPhone that,
are you hearing me okay?
Yeah,
I put the iPhone.
Okay.
You opened video and you put,
you put,
you press record and you record yourself and then you,
you just show the whole thing and then when you're done go like,
oh my gosh,
I didn't mean to do that.
Like it's an accident.
I kept going to those who did it
well,
yeah,
I mean,
I mean I think that's part of the appeal is they're like,
oh,
this is Tom's mom.
She's farting
a lot of gambling.
This could supplement your retirement.
Um,
I mean maybe pee in a cup.
I'll look into it.
Hello.
Talk to him for a second please.
Hey Tommy.
Hey,
what's up man?
The end.
What are you doing?
What number are you calling from?
Mom did,
wasn't going to answer.
It's a,
it's my office line is in the office.
Ah,
okay.
Um,
yeah,
just people were like asking a bunch of questions about,
cause they heard about mom's farts and they're like,
well,
we want to see them.
And then they showed me this site where,
where we can upload her farting and that people are willing to pay for it.
You know?
That is crazy.
Yeah.
Do you by any,
anyone,
any chance?
Do you want to do far videos too
for money?
I would do four videos all day,
but I mean it might,
it might sour your reputation around town.
That's the only thing I would feel.
I have to tell you.
Could you have to be on camera?
Oh wait.
She has to part with her face being shown.
Yeah.
Now she's saying,
I know why know the as well.
I just sold on,
she's only had like a couple of sips of our wine and I,
by the end of the glass of wine,
I'm sure curious will be down.
Okay.
Yeah.
You look,
you look so good.
I'm so proud of you.
I really am.
Well,
thank you very much.
Thank you.
Um,
all right,
I'll uh,
I'll,
I'll let you guys have lunch and then give me a call later,
okay.
Okay.
Okay,
good.
All right.
Bye.
All right,
bye.
That was pretty amazing.
That was perfect timing.
Your mom was on board until we had to show her face.
Yeah.
And she had,
um,
I was like couple thousand now and she was like,
I don't know,
it's gross.
I'm like,
well,
what does it take three?
She has moved it up $1,000 and was like,
Oh,
far for $1,000.
I mean,
I do feel like $3,000 is reasonable for fart videos.
So that's a really good,
good rate.
What is that?
That's 36 grand a year.
That's more than some teachers make.
Absolutely.
I mean,
yeah,
you're never going to have a legitimate job again,
but do you want one?
And she's a 70 something years old.
That's,
that's she's going to,
yeah,
that's,
that's retirement.
That granny fart mistress.
That's pretty,
it's a really good idea.
It looks she's,
she's in retirement.
She doesn't want to work.
I mean,
that will supplement your income.
Yeah.
Your retirement,
whatever checks that they get from the government.
Sure.
And I think it'd be,
you know,
I'd like to be known as the comedian who's mom.
Yes.
Spark videos.
I mean,
I think that would help my brand.
Yeah.
That's the biggest incentive for me to is people are going to have her start
opening for me on the road.
Interesting.
You guys want to see the grantee farts,
right?
She comes out,
puts a mic to her butt goes.
Ah,
my son.
Yeah.
I mean,
it seems like a really good idea and the best part is you could spend time
together on the road.
Yeah.
You can just travel with your mom.
You can stay in the same hotel room as your mom.
You guys really get close,
you know?
Yeah.
That'd be really cool.
And then marry your mom and then we'd have to really start.
But again,
of what interests me is we really have to start paying attention to what she
eats to get the right,
you know?
Right.
Dirty
bit.
Yeah.
Well,
thankfully she's already on a diet that's high gas producing.
That's right.
She already is.
Yeah.
Which is why
I can't,
I can't get enough.
I know.
She said I can't get enough of her if I know who she was.
Yeah.
But you know what?
It does a disservice to the fun of not knowing who she is.
Right.
And we don't want to violate anybody's private privacy.
Yeah.
We enjoy her,
but we don't want her to get bombarded by people.
Paul,
the voice more and the imagination more than this is who it is,
you know?
Yeah.
I feel like it's more fun that way personally,
but we do know what she looks like is what you're saying.
Yeah.
So can we at least describe her to the audience?
I'll just say we were both wrong.
Yeah.
Well we can say that.
You know,
I don't want to,
well,
not now.
There's a face to it.
It changes the dynamic set of Burnett,
like a malady.
Burnett.
She was a Brunette before she went gray,
so we can say that she's great.
Yeah,
but she had been bed big honkers big slops.
Yeah.
She's an older lady and she's real.
I'd say she's just stocky,
like thick.
Yeah.
Kind of like thicker legs and yeah.
Broader,
older.
Not at,
not at the fatty or anything like that.
Right now,
by the way,
I want to mention this.
I mentioned at the top when we did all our stuff,
but I know there's people that skip all that.
Um,
so I have to mention it once during the show.
And that is if a,
if you're in mum straight Lya um,
you and you skip the top.
I am having to move my dates due to a scheduling conflict.
I,
I tried to move it twice,
two sooner.
Um,
and it,
it'd be Doodoo venue availability.
It's moved till April.
You said do,
do,
uh,
availability is moved to April.
And I know that's a ways away.
That's just the way it worked out.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm sorry that it's put off that long,
but that's just the way it is.
So the,
um,
the tickets are still good for your,
for the new shows you've probably been contacted.
If you don't want to go,
you can get a refund,
but that's,
um,
that's just the way it is.
So I apologize.
But that's what is going to happen with that.
Okay.
So I had to tell him,
um,
I wanted to bring up a topic now.
You started to talk about it yesterday when you got home from your long journey.
Yes.
Yeah.
Which I have to say was awesome in the dirty,
dirty.
Yeah.
So thank you to everybody that was in those cities.
Uh,
Richmond,
Virginia Beach,
Greensboro,
Asheville,
and uh,
Charleston,
which is where my sister is,
which is who I was just speaking to.
So I got to hang out with her a little bit and the shows were bananas member I
was announcing on this show that Charleston,
I was like,
we need you to get some tickets in the last week leading up to the show.
The ticket sales doubled.
Wow.
For that.
Fantastic.
That's mommy power right there.
Yeah.
It's pretty crazy.
That's the power of the jeans.
Yeah.
Gene powers.
Um,
so you came home and I,
you started to talk about how you actually preferred plain shits.
And I go and I go stop you right there.
I'm going to write that down.
Come up from some moose soup and we'll talk about this on the shelf.
That's true.
I was starting to tell you and you're like,
just stop,
save it.
Save it.
As I was saying was this,
there's no better place to shit that in your own house.
That's number one.
Yeah.
And then if you're,
if you're traveling your hotel room,
you have your privacy,
you have your own amenities.
I know,
but you,
I mean like you can jump in the shower,
you can do what you want it,
it's still like a mo your travel home.
Right.
So you're still,
once you leave there,
the only thing I like about the plane as opposed to let's say the airport stall
is that it sucks.
It sucks shitting on a plane.
Yeah.
Sucks.
I get like I get performance anxiety.
That's the one,
that's her worst part.
But here's the good part.
You're shitting there right where your left elbow or right elbow is depending on
the layout of that plane is the sink.
It's right there.
And they usually,
in my experience have like piping hot water.
So what I'll do is I'll shit and then not toilet toilet paper is,
is on planes is really low quality.
I hate that.
So I'll take paper towels because they're thicker and I'll soak them in piping
hot water and then I'll start to wash my ass hole with that.
And I get,
I get the sensation eventually of being so clean because I'm,
I'm using a thicker paper that doesn't tear like their toilet.
They're cheap.
Toilet paper does.
And I have hot water cleaning out that area.
So I actually prefer that to an airport stall because I don't feel as clean.
What you're saying is you like the proximity of the sink to the toilet and that
is something that enhances the whole misery,
the toilet shit.
Because if you're in the stall,
if you're like,
I want to,
I want that.
You'd have to leave your stall.
Ah,
a wet something under the sink.
Go back to the stall.
Like you know,
I've done that by the way I've done it,
but it's a much more tedious.
And you've done that in public?
Yeah.
I swear.
I swear in an airport you're not afraid.
And what do you do with your pants?
You leave them around your ankles.
Well,
no.
What I did was like,
I cleaned up well,
but I was like,
I want another level of claims.
So I went out wet toilet paper in front of people,
took it back into the store.
Shut the,
did you pull your pants up over your dirty ass holes?
Yeah.
But I also left the buckle and stuff open.
I left the paint everybody near one news.
I was cleaning my ass.
Yeah.
But guys don't care guys.
Guys don't care.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's so nasty.
It was the last time you did that this week.
One of these years I was in five airports.
I don't know.
I wasn't,
I was into airports,
right?
Three,
I don't fucking remember.
I wasn't one of them though.
Maybe O'Hare.
I did it in.
Oh,
that's a good way.
I think it's a huge airport.
That's a fucking,
can I read an to you before we
roll along here?
Sure.
Um,
I think it's kind of fitting apropos our current discussion.
Hold on.
Oh Geez.
Okay.
Here we go.
As,
okay.
Hi,
Mommy's as the water champ of Bristol,
England.
While staying exceptionally hydrated,
I have switched to a water meter from a fixed fee water billing system as an
incentive to save water lest the reservoirs run dry due to my advanced water
intake.
As I am now paying per flush,
I have to put a cap of two flushes per brown.
This means there are,
there is sometimes a little fun buoyant Brown Nugget remaining in the book which
me,
which my gene is obliged to Brown on top of before using any of her assigned
flushes.
Fucking crazy.
She thinks that our browns touching is weird.
It didn't know she touches my wiener.
I like to sell her this idea by pointing out that the little brown is probably
lonely and needs a few down pedal nuggets to support it into the murky world of
the British sewage system.
Please could you confirm or deny if you have a similar Negi Buddy policy or if
you enforce a water wasteful flush till gone system waste,
wasted up,
waste all that water.
Now I,
I'm afraid I'm going to have to call you out here a little bit,
but I would say half the time I go to use the toilet,
there's one in your little brown nuggies floating.
Others not,
yeah.
What?
There's a lot of your brown eggs or you,
what you do is you leave a final wiper of paper and you leave it just at the
bottom of the time.
Yes.
Can I leave a lot of teeny tiny nuggets?
I don't know how.
All right,
I flush and then I can say this.
Or you waste the water though.
Of course.
I wasted say that.
I don't ever intend for nuggets to be there.
Um,
the,
the last sheet of paper is a trademark.
Something I've been doing for you have been,
I want people to know that like I was there,
but I don't,
I don't do it with nuggets.
You wasn't shit on my nugget.
You would flush before.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
I know.
Automatic automatic to me.
Me Too.
I think it's disgusting.
And I don't understand this 12 flushing system you guys have.
That sounds terrible.
And here
in America we just waste use nasty bro.
And I also got an email from a couple who they um,
they're browns seem to come on at the same time in the morning and they,
I'm assuming have one toilet.
No,
you and I had one toilet for a million years.
And what did we do when we both had the brown at the same time?
I think w I think what happens is we realize that when you say I gotta go shit,
you can hold it for another hour before you can hold it for a while.
Yeah.
Whereas when I say I got to shit,
it means I have to go now.
So you're like,
I got to
go in the next 30 seconds.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
Why do you have an emergency system in there?
I mean it's just like you should be like,
oh,
I got a signal.
I should do this later.
It's like a flare.
Yeah,
no,
I got an interesting email.
Yeah.
This is really for me.
But you can comment on this too,
since actually the two of us can,
can,
can comment.
So this is a Chubby chaser seeking advice.
She writes,
hello,
Tommy and Tina.
I am writing because I have a problem I think you may be able to help me with.
About a year ago I met a guy at a friend's wedding.
We got along great dancing,
joking together most of the night.
At the end of the night he asked for my number and I didn't hesitate to give it
to him.
We joke around,
flirt a lot through texts and snapchat often saying we went to hang out,
but nothing has come to fruition.
Usually I would tell this fuck boy to kiss my pussy and not worry about it as he
obviously wears his pants low and loose,
but I have a theory I may be able to,
uh,
you may be able to offer some insight on this guy has chubby.
I make fitness,
all of the fitness.
I take very good.
Sarah care of myself.
I'm in very good shape.
Could this have anything to do with his hesitation to pull the trigger and see
me again?
I usually date other fit people.
So I do not have a frame of reference for this adorable doughboy.
Maybe insecurity keeps him from wanting to take his clothes off in front of me.
Maybe he will feel you feel judged.
Maybe it's just like the case seeing as how Tommy used to be fat and mommy time.
Tina was obviously into it.
I was wondering if you two could give me some words of wisdom.
Maybe this is a better question for burnt Chrysler seeing as he is still fat.
Thanks Hitler.
Brittany think it's an excellent question and it brings a lot of discussion
points to light.
Um,
number one,
let's go through the possibilities.
Number one,
there is one possibility that this guy is not interested.
That's a possibility.
Yeah,
but he did ask for her number,
so that's why I would probably take that.
I mean take that kind of off the table.
He has a girlfriend or somebody who is seeing right now.
Maybe those are possible,
but maybe she,
she would,
she,
if they're communicating he would probably,
she would probably know if he has a girlfriend,
you know,
it's possible.
So I'm saying that's option one,
he's not indoor.
Option two could be that you're totally correct and that he is just super
insecure,
in which case I think just like no matter what somebody's insecurities are,
they need reassurance.
They need reassurance that you are not,
um,
that like that you're attracted to them,
you know?
So,
and also I would say that guys,
regardless of their bodies and physiques,
most of the time need to be hit on the head with information,
especially when it comes to a lot of guys don't assume that you're attracted.
I mean there's the chaser.
There's a guy
that's always,
but a lot of guys are the [inaudible]
type that go,
I didn't know your into me,
you know,
like I,
I feel like maybe women,
um,
I'm making assumptions here are more of the opposite of that.
But I feel like a lot of guys are the types that are like,
I'm not going to assume that it's a reciprocated.
Yeah,
it's funny.
I think it's the exact opposite.
I think a lot of men assume that you're in to them when you just say hello.
Oh,
you're like fuck me.
I'm like,
I know.
Just being nice.
Yeah,
I could see that.
I guess it goes for both sexes in,
because I had nice,
that's why you're a decent man and that's why you don't assume that everyone
wants to fuck you because you are actually sweet human being,
which is why I married you.
I usually did not assume that of course,
because you're a nice guy.
I like nice guys.
I married the best one.
That's why I had to be told yes directly by people,
you know.
Yeah,
but that's why you're special and that's why I think you're the absolute best
human being and that's why we're married and we've been together for 12 years.
Cause I,
I adore you for that.
Oh that's very sweet.
And you're not a Douche bag.
No,
I wouldn't.
Blame is,
wait,
it sounds like she's wait focused here.
Well she's,
she's bringing about an interesting point because what she's saying is that
she's super fit.
He's not,
they do communicate.
They do flirt.
They do tag.
Okay.
He's not pulling the trigger.
She's into him.
How does she,
like,
my point would be that I'm trying to put myself in the guy's position.
Maybe if she is correct and her assumption that he's insecure about it.
What,
what helps is reassurance.
Right,
right,
right.
So you actually have to be in,
if that's the case,
more blatant yet to be blamed that you're okay with him not being into fitness.
Well,
not in the fitness and like without saying like even though you're this,
it's like I'm attracted to you.
Right.
I like this.
Yeah.
The thing is he's probably freaking like,
I don't want to run 10 miles a day to hang out with this chick.
I don't want to go to the gym.
This is not something I don't wear a lifestyle different.
Right.
This isn't going to work.
That fit.
Yeah.
Cause she sound like she makes fitness in her all the time.
All the fitness.
Yeah.
So she makes all the fitness.
He makes none of the fitness.
Yeah.
Now the reason you and I worked I think is because I had the soul of a fat
person.
Always.
Yeah.
I never wanted to go exercising with you.
So we weren't so divergent on lifestyle.
The lifestyle is a thing,
but you can also,
it's also good and I think in relationship to have some different interests,
things that I do is things that you do that are not your like go dig.
I read books,
not true words and,
but so she could be the type that's like,
I'm going to go fucking rock climbing.
And he's like,
that sounds terrible.
Bake something.
I Dunno.
Like it could just be,
but he needs reassurance.
Yeah.
You should,
you reassurance and obvious like,
and I mean,
I know that like,
you're like,
well,
pull the trigger,
but maybe you got it.
Be like,
Hey,
I'm this Saturday,
um,
no,
whatever's going on or I know this bar or I want to see this move.
Like,
just make
it audience.
Yeah.
And then,
and then when you're with him,
you know,
make your interests obvious.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
whatever.
It's like,
you don't have to be like,
pull that dig out,
but you start,
you know,
get handsy.
Put the hands on the back thigh hands.
You know thy hands.
That's really forward.
Yeah.
But you do it like for a second.
You don't leave it there.
Right.
You just give him a signal.
The signal is like,
Hey,
I like you.
Or if he needs the reassurance grace,
like,
oh,
I got it.
It was too much reaching for the Napkin.
Oops.
Did I?
Every guy knows that thigh hands are like,
oh yeah.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Because it's not,
it's not,
um,
it's not slutty.
It's like,
it's a signal.
It's just like,
I like you,
it's,
I like you.
This is a part of your body that's not,
um,
like a too personal to touch.
Right.
But it's enough to send you the signal that this hand can go higher and your
leg.
Did I let you know that I liked you?
How did you know that I liked you eventually?
Um,
well,
you know,
I had a little heads up from your friend and that's what it was.
Yeah.
So he was like,
you know,
there's an open door.
Here is what he told him.
Like you can,
you can make a phone call and uh,
see what's up with this bet,
you know?
And I was like,
that's what he said.
And then I was like,
well pitch pitches that again like with how we talk.
hit me up with those digits real quick and you're sweet.
I was like,
so
bitch,
I reminded you.
Um,
one time we were in like in like dating,
courting early phases of our,
you know,
thing whenever we were friends first.
So we transitioned from friendship to dating.
Yeah.
And I remember being like,
oh,
are you going to so and so's party this weekend?
Yeah,
no,
yeah,
you're going to my,
and you go and then you didn't go.
And I was hoping to see you there and then I talk to you later and you're all,
oh,
I fell asleep on the couch.
I was like,
this is,
remember some,
we don't have a house phone in here
and he probably doesn't have a self phone.
Definitely doesn't.
Great.
We got to go get one that's um,
press pause,
pause and wait till a,
the weasel gets here.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Be wheezy.
The weasels a different part.
I know.
You know what I mean though.
We'll be back in a moment.
Okay.
Mommy and we set up the way obviously for a moment there but we are back.
We're joined by our guests that we teased earlier in the show.
You want to talk some shit?
He's here with us right now.
The creator of the,
you want to talk some shit?
Yeah,
the 800 party gangster party line.
Oh my God.
The wheezy Brent.
Why Umbach is here.
It does.
Nice intro and a nice little tight little soundbite too.
Yeah,
it was a tight bite type.
I like those type fights.
Yeah.
I will say that the gangster party line is my hands down like my favorite sketch
ever done ever.
It's so funny.
And and,
and you actually had that phone number up for a walk.
It's still up.
People still call it all the time.
We could take calls,
we should actually maybe try to take calls if it's an easy setup.
All I need is the log in and do a g mail account and we can take calls,
the sand talk all the time.
It's still,
you know,
all the time during the day.
And what did they say?
What's the,
uh,
sometimes it's just hang up.
Sometimes they just say something short,
you know,
but sometimes they go on rants and I mean,
we posted a lot of the messages that people would leave,
uh,
you know,
on this website,
gangster party,
line.com,
and there's all kinds of fun.
You even did,
your online sketch was such a success that even did like a follow up.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We just,
we took some calls,
you know.
How did you produce it?
Like how did you,
Oh,
uh,
just,
you know,
La puts put a notice up on La casting and Craig's list and,
um,
that was pretty much it.
My friend had a house that we could use.
Uh,
where did you hold your casting sessions?
Did you find that office?
Yeah,
my,
we use my friend's families business,
uh,
like some on the weekend.
Okay.
We use the,
an office in there and have people come in on the weekend.
Yeah.
The dude that played like the,
the face of,
you know,
yeah.
The main,
the main gangster.
Yeah,
he had like a very Leland white,
his name is a very,
a accent for delivery of the lines.
Oh,
you thought so.
I thought Oh,
interesting.
Yeah.
Like what was that?
Learning about California way.
There's like,
there's a California diction for that.
Like I think especially if you listened to a lot of hip hop,
some guys can say certain words and you're like,
oh,
that's a west coast guy.
You know?
That's interesting.
I mean,
is there any specific thing specific you can,
uh,
I mean for people that don't know,
yeah,
we can write,
there's no like course licensing.
Very few.
I mean like we were such a huge fan of the sketch that we may talk to their
fans.
I got,
I got some news for you and a little bit.
Oh really?
Well,
yeah,
there's going to be more,
more gangster party line.
Well,
more hotline videos in one more gangster party line video.
Really.
You've been making them?
Yeah.
May earlier this year have made a,
it was,
it was a huge project,
but there was,
um,
made five hotline,
new hotline videos,
one of them being SQL to gauge the party line.
But then the other four are different themes,
different party lines.
Basically.
Where should we go for it?
Where do you like it to be played off of Youtube?
Sure.
Youtube that's go to the source.
I mean these days do I type in Brent Wine Bach?
Sure.
You go to my youtube channel,
youtube.com/brand wine bug.
Okay.
I'm going to do that right now.
And you know,
there's other cool videos of their too.
If people are interest.
Yeah.
You have no,
you have a bunch of good ones.
So Brent Leinbach professional magician.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
All,
all right,
hold on.
Here we go.
All right.
By the way.
Well,
I'll get into this later.
You didn't watch that video link I sent you a little while back.
You told me not to.
Good,
good,
good.
And we're going to play it today.
We should.
Do you have it?
Well,
you can access it online.
Yes.
Okay.
All right,
here we go.
So Nigga,
you want to talk some shit went out the La Isms to actually start some shit.
Bitch sub full.
You gotta Talk Shit about me Homie.
That's definitely west coast.
This is waiting for your motherfucking call and that's you right during the
voiceover?
No really it sounds like talking shit about that.
Really?
That sounds like me.
Yeah.
Well so let's shit call these motherfuckers asap.
That to me even like,
just the way he said that to me seems like a west coast guy.
Interesting.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Says some shit.
What the fuck you on your boss.
What about him?
Hmm?
Where do you think he's from?
Cause I know you know where he's from.
Yeah.
And I also,
yeah,
I do know where he's from and I can really hear it too.
Okay,
let's,
let's listen again.
Okay.
Yeah.
Says some shit.
What the fuck you on your boss purse?
The hardest Niggas is standing by.
Ready to pick up that phone.
Both Niggas,
Dork Niggers,
Asian American,
White Niggas Suck my dick.
Bitch.
Fuck you.
One,
two,
one,
three,
seventh.
Well,
the that phone,
the numbers are super west coast.
Oh,
you think so?
I know.
I'm just saying the intentions are not that the way that three is hit.
That's super west.
Oh,
can you play that again?
The three?
Yeah.
It's interesting.
By the way,
that the guy who was the bone spurs guy.
Yeah.
That Guy's east coast and you can hear it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think.
Hmm.
One,
two,
one three bitch.
Yeah.
One fuck you.
[inaudible] two,
one,
three,
seven,
four,
two,
five,
three,
three.
You will,
that's interesting for knickers.
Plastic Niggas,
classic racists Niggas,
mystery Niggas Cycle Niggas.
Y'All niggas Jewish sneakers,
motherfucking nerves calling me.
I'll box.
It's a little bullshit ass Nigga got a calm that shit down and come right here.
Show me some fucking respect for me and my Jewish Nigga come up here and beat
your ass niggas.
Okay.
That guy mostly and mostly it was improvising and I told him hit Shabbat.
I said,
you got some nerve calling me,
I should buy.
I told him,
you know,
say that.
Yeah.
I said,
there's a couple of other things and told him to hit,
but a lot of this,
he's just kind of,
he was really good,
and I think I said this in the followup video,
but he's really good at improvising or playing,
doing it loose.
But whenever we tried to do things on the by lines,
he wasn't able to limit it as much.
The great thing about him appearing here in the,
as far as like in the,
the,
um,
the ordinary is that this absolutely,
like,
just when you feel like you've hit,
got the joke,
got the,
yeah,
this dude completes,
he shuts it down.
And it also helps,
like if you're listening right now to see him and to see the way he says this,
like the way that he looks around where he's almost like,
part of you is like,
he's trying to remember what to say,
but part of you,
he's like,
you know,
he,
he doesn't really stop.
He goes,
yeah,
it's,
um,
it's definitely,
he was awesome.
He did a great job and he'll be
finding it to the side.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh Man.
I can't wait for you guys to see you.
The next,
the secrets of off top,
that was him
for 99 per minute.
That was me right there for 99 per minute.
The gangster part,
it's free.
It's free.
You know,
he could,
okay.
Now I listened to it.
I May,
maybe it was like my memory of all the different voices.
Yeah.
So maybe it's not him,
so maybe it's been narrator.
The narrator I definitely felt was west coast has shit though.
Yeah.
Okay.
Am I right?
Uh,
yeah.
I guess.
I Dunno.
Yeah,
I dunno where I think he is.
Yeah.
You don't know.
I think he's,
I think he's west coast.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll tell you more later.
Say more later.
All right.
And this guy,
Leland,
I don't know where he's from originally.
Um,
he lives in,
he lives in California
medical medicine recently.
He's in the,
he's in the upcoming,
he's in the new one as well.
Leland Leland.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's some other fun surprises too.
All right.
I mean,
this is all cheeses.
I know.
I'm just like watching the fucking ass on Hbo and that as Hardcore Right now.
Well,
I'll tell you more about it.
Okay.
So there's,
there's,
there's a new case,
the party line.
I will say when you see it,
it's going to seem like an overkill of gangster.
We'd felt idea was just,
it was going to be more gangs,
an excessive amount of gangsters this time.
More of a right.
Just more gangsters.
And it's like a lot.
All the roll out on your youtube channel.
No,
it's for um,
Kevin Hart's new,
uh,
digital network called laugh out loud network and a,
I think it's supposed to come out in August,
but um,
they will streamline the,
in other words,
it will be like one,
and I don't want to sure how they're going to release them exactly.
But I'll,
I'll probably promote them and I'm hoping that at one point I'll be able to
share the director's cuts because those are the ones I wear.
My,
the ones I would have wanted to go out,
but of course,
but the ones that they have or they're still good.
But you know,
there was things that we see it when they want us to take out or whatever.
And you know,
like they're the one that's coming out on the laugh out loud network is two
minutes long for the gangster party line.
The one,
the director's got three minutes.
So you're getting a whole,
you know,
there's a third missing from the wow.
But as the third,
is that a bummer?
I hate editing stuff down.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
but anyway,
there's that.
So there's a gangster party like coming out,
Leland,
we'll be back and maybe some others too.
Mothers familiar faces and busy then then.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Those,
these hotline videos took up a lot of time this year.
It was like,
and congrats on doing that with the,
it looks like a production team behind you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
it was a,
yeah.
You go pitch this idea to them.
Well,
they just really liked the original and um,
they,
they were,
they kind of pitched it to me in a way.
Well,
I,
I had ideas that were related to gangster party line and um,
like getting celebrities to answer the,
the line or maybe animating some of the voicemails and stuff or whatever.
And there they just said,
what about some other hotlines to other things?
I want to,
uh,
um,
you made this,
the dance was that,
that,
that short film.
Oh,
I don't dance.
Can people see that I watched it on Vimeo.
Yeah.
Thanks for mentioning.
If you just Google that.
Yeah.
Just go to my Vimeo page is vimeo.com/brent wine.
Barco Watch.
I don't dance and don't,
don't get impatient.
Don't it is 20 minutes.
You have to sit down short film.
Yeah.
It's a short film.
You have to sit down and take time.
They'll watch it.
Yeah.
I don't think,
I don't know if Christine has seen it.
I've seen it.
It's really great.
And,
um,
you know,
I know I spent a lot of time on it and we,
I hope I w I like people to and that as much,
I don't know if this is like a series.
Another thing you did was like,
when you're like the magician doing tricks on the street to come mind Jack Mine
Jackline Jazz.
Great.
Oh thanks.
Thanks.
Yeah.
The new thing though that you're teasing.
How long is it?
Oh,
it's like a two minutes.
Two minutes.
Okay.
You guys should definitely watch it.
Um,
why don't we,
can we watch it right now?
Did you want to get into it now or did you oh yeah,
I was going to tell you some more about those other hotlines,
videos,
whatever you want.
If you want to know whatever you want,
I think it's exciting to play to that.
Why don't we have a debut,
but let's get a video.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now here's the thing.
I almost don't want you to even see the title of the video and I wonder if I
should pull it up and just full screen.
And so you don't know what the title is even,
um,
or do you want to know the title?
I just,
I think for simplicity,
just,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
It probably be easier for me to,
he's typing.
Okay.
So,
uh,
let's go to the Vimeo.
Like,
cause there's a bunch of re uploads of it.
Like it was with a magic video.
Dot.
Yeah.
Brian.
Brian,
why buck?
Yeah,
it's called man gives birth.
Okay.
Well that's really apropos.
Are Opening.
Click.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So,
okay.
I see it about orgasms.
Yeah.
This one's,
this one's like definitely kind of,
it's a little more hardcore,
so,
okay.
Watch it.
Hardcore is what we're all about.
I've given birth so I don't,
I'm not screamed Dodo.
Y'All feel like it actually from that perspective,
that
Ryan Singer,
Brian Singer,
yeah.
Man is a no,
this is be good for you guys to get your reaction.
I think.
Don't your doctors are around
him.
I was like,
they're preparing.
He's nervous.
I have to narrate a little fruit.
Please.
He's,
it looks like he's,
uh,
getting comfortable or uncomfortable with being my dad.
He's got his hog.
You can see this big painter.
Something was just inserted inside of them.
They're putting Vaseline on his deck right now.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's a close up of his penis.
That penis,
he's pushing really hard,
like he's delivering birth.
Oh my.
Oh my God.
And there's something about to come out the head of his penis right now.
Oh.
And the penis is growing.
Oh,
really?
Struggling washout.
Whatever's in there.
Oh my goodness.
This is quite a visual
sketch because heads being like,
oh,
I love seeing you guys react to that.
They're lubing his pay whole.
Yeah.
Oh,
they're cutting his penis
to get the baby out.
Oh,
was
stick open.
Ooh.
Oh,
Gotcha.
Ah,
yeah.
Just straight his penis.
Yes.
His Dick is just completely gone now.
This is,
um,
God,
Brynne world's first ever man.
Birth successful.
Wow.
Thanks for that,
Brent.
Yeah.
Thank you for funny.
There's historic brick.
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a context for that.
Why that says that.
But it was meant to be on the,
uh,
it was originally on the dark web and it was meant to seem like a red room
video.
Oh,
right.
And um,
wow.
It looks real.
That's very real.
Yeah.
No,
he went over,
there was a budget behind that.
I was going to say it was for TV show was it was for the Internet,
but for TV shows with the,
you know,
the,
the aspect of that.
Yeah.
Uh,
this girl,
this is a woman named Chloe.
I mean,
she did a phenomenal job.
Sends it does I think her last name?
Chloe sens.
Yeah.
She,
it was her first.
I just thought you bought a Dildo and I was like,
oh,
they just have it like a fake dick there.
But when it starts moving and growing,
yeah,
no,
she did a great job and everybody involved was that Ryan's real dick.
I mean,
they do.
She did a great job with Ryan's plan.
Yeah.
That baby it loaded.
It took some,
took some exercise.
He just had a stretches,
you know,
he had,
he had a week of preparation of just,
uh,
you know,
stretching his penis in and out.
Uh,
yeah.
He just had to let me ask you a question.
So,
um,
oh yeah,
please ask them what you ever date your mom?
Did you ever doubt your mom?
No,
not me.
You know,
I mean,
no,
and I know,
I think I know,
hey,
we're asking that,
but I wouldn't though.
You think you know how I'm asking it.
Let me give you some more context.
I'm your mom and you're my son and I if falling in love with him,
are you really?
I think
I was scared to let you know too.
I am too.
We're both consenting.
Adults hold up.
It comes down to it,
you know,
it's just like the gays there,
you know?
As long as they're all routine,
everything's fine.
All right.
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I don't just prove that I'm okay with that,
but I mean,
I wouldn't do it.
There's a little bit,
by the way,
the context was,
would you date someone who wasn't related?
They were,
they were your mom,
but you're not related.
I thought that was the question,
biological guy.
Like I thought you were asking me if they were no me.
I mean like if they were exactly what they were exactly like your mom,
but you weren't actually related to them.
No.
And I thought that's what you were asking.
What can I steal your real mom?
I just,
I wouldn't,
I,
I wouldn't date her,
you know?
Why is that?
Because,
um,
I,
you know,
she's just a,
I don't know.
There's just a different thing.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Again,
if I wasn't related to them,
I wouldn't date my dad either,
but yeah.
But this I approve of because,
because I would date my biological mom.
No,
I'm just kidding.
I worked eight.
I,
I mean,
I just,
I,
you know,
whatever they could do what they want,
who cares?
They're not,
you know,
they do what they want.
Of course.
It's like the gaze
that is important to point out that the gays do what they want and so can
everyone else yeah.
As long as they're 18.
Yeah.
It's an important why,
why do they have to go to jail for 18 months?
Then they actually ended up,
they ended up getting arrested and everything.
Why that's not right.
Um,
I guess there are a great team that,
I mean the,
yeah,
they wanted to get married,
but he could,
he could technically fuck his mom.
What do you guys,
how do you guys feel?
I feel like it's gross,
but he,
if he wants to fuck his mom,
I don't care.
But if you start wanting to like have a marriage ceremony,
not that it,
it affects,
affects me in any way,
but that's where the legal system is going to jump in and be like,
no,
you can't.
And I think that's what would caught up to that.
I wonder why,
but why not?
But you know what though,
they don't even need to get married.
You know what I mean?
There are lots of stairs.
They didn't need to do this interview either,
you know,
but he could have just kept fucking his mom and he got,
they got,
they got off.
They didn't get in trouble for this.
They have very little.
Is there a law against it?
Yeah.
You can't marry your mom,
you know,
but can you have intercourse with,
I don't think legally.
I mean again,
you could do it,
but I think if you announce it is where somebody goes,
you can't fuck your mom.
They have,
they should have just fucked and then not like not told people.
Oh were they real public about it?
Yeah,
they have like pride.
Their,
their pride.
Pride,
pride.
LGBT.
Yeah.
Ms Ms or mess or sm there.
S and m.
Did they do SNM that's right.
Sudden Mom's right.
Set amongst the definition of medicine is real.
That's the real
honest truth.
Yes,
I would because 19 years you're the best thing that ever happened to me and I
really want to be with the rest of my life.
I wonder how much older is she is
they both have cool face tat down.
I'm down for you.
I'm actually down for them straight up.
Really?
I'm John for a lot of things.
Yeah.
I mean I'm down for people to do a lot of things.
As long as it's not hurting anybody.
Yeah,
sure you are.
Who are you dating?
This girl named mom?
No,
I'm just kidding.
This,
this,
this woman.
This young woman.
I mean,
I don't know.
what else is there?
Not a comedian.
Regular person.
That's good.
Got It.
Got to keep it real.
Keep it real like you guys,
you know,
two years,
two years.
You got a real,
this is like a real fucking just real relationship.
You give a roses and stuff.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
I've given a roses before.
Take her out to eat and stuff.
Yeah.
Like um,
you know Barney's beanery.
What about on the Americana?
You know,
what about the place where you ride the bull?
You were taking her there in San Diego?
No,
no.
Saddle ranch.
Oh,
the Saddleback ranch.
They have a boulder go I to take her there,
man.
We got to ride that bull together.
I want to meet.
It's like a bull made for too.
Are you guys tell us more about her off the air?
I,
yeah,
sure.
Right?
Yeah.
What else do you want to know?
What's up man?
Do you guys heart in front of each other?
No,
I don't.
I have farted in previous relationships,
but I don't,
not in this one.
Wow.
What's special about her that you just don't,
I don't want to do that.
I'm,
I'm getting,
you know,
you guys Fart,
right?
Hardcore
show entirely about farming.
But how many years in did you guys start farting?
Two months.
How many months
when I met you guys,
which wasn't,
it wasn't a month to,
you know what I remember why,
because I could,
there's a couple things that I remember looking at him reminiscing.
I remember,
I remember the timeline here.
Here's how I remember.
Yeah,
I start seeing you in late.
Um,
oh like I go out a couple of times to do an o four oh five oh four oh five I
know that I was dating you officially cause we shot cut in oh five I remember
that.
Right.
And I remembered that that fart happened in college football season.
So it had to be at least September.
Right.
I don't know exactly why you're thinking all this.
I'm on board.
2005 is when he's
started dating.
Let's say January is like we're dating.
Oh,
okay.
And then the first top part has in football season,
which is in the fall,
which is in the fall.
So I know it's at least nine months of fall apart.
Fall apart.
How you did it.
This is how I broke the fart barrier.
Are you ready?
Sure.
I spent the night at her place.
I remember that it's football season cause I was watching on her Shitty TV,
a college game in on a Saturday morning and I was sitting there in my boxers.
She sat next to me and I was like,
oh man.
And at this point,
you know we're definitely dating.
It's like,
you know,
you're in the mix.
We're in there.
We probably did it last night or this morning and now I'm just like chilling,
watching football.
And I go,
I feel this far coming and I just go for it.
But I grabbed her hand and I put it between my legs and I fart on her hand.
That's the first fart.
Whoa.
That is very bold.
It's like all or nothing kind of thing.
Part on her hand.
And she goes,
oh my God.
I said,
Mary,
she goes,
it smells like garbage.
It smells like garbage.
And she ran into the other room.
Oh yeah,
it did.
It smell like garbage.
I know those garbage farts.
I don't do them myself,
but I have a friend,
I won't mention his name.
He is a comedian.
Um,
but it is,
yeah,
he has these,
we've talked about it on stage and does it really him?
It was,
yeah,
it is.
Well,
you know what,
it was more so in the past when he had a very,
it seems like he had a stricter vegan diet then he had that real calm posty kind
of,
you know,
it really,
it was this vegetarian,
these vegetarian farts are Vegan farts.
They're very,
uh,
they smell like garbage.
They still like real garbage.
Garbage.
People should tweet them.
You should tweet them.
You should tweet.
Moesha um,
I heard your bars.
I feel,
I hope he doesn't get upset about me.
So man,
I'm not a big deal.
I mean,
I said no,
when I said a big deal,
it's just that you could have been like,
no,
but you,
you know.
So what did you think when you put your hand on the farm,
what did you think now in retrospect,
if I had high self esteem or like standards that were different,
I thought I probably wouldn't be like,
I gotta I gotta get out of this.
You know?
Yeah.
I think because back then I was like,
I'm a comedian,
I'm silly,
carefree person.
I would just kind of rolled with it.
Oh,
okay.
And I liked him.
So wait a second,
I'm out.
Like now that I'm older and kind of like looking for flags,
I think I was my guard,
my defenses were down.
Wow.
So you're saying if he farted on your hand now,
what would you have done?
Would you been like,
I'm out of get out of my,
but again,
it's not date.
This is like nine months plus we were before we dated,
so I knew that he was going to do that.
He farted back,
but you gotta get it done now.
This could have been a point.
You could have said something like maybe if it was,
if you rewind back,
if you had been like,
hey,
just so you know,
I really don't ever want to do like I'm not good with that.
That could have established some boundaries.
That's the thing is that I could have established boundaries.
It could have been like,
uh,
how was you felt?
Did Not react to that.
Yeah.
What would you like positive way,
you know,
you laughed I guess.
And truth be told,
I'm glad we have open fart policy.
Farted on each others face like as a joke or not as a joke in our son's face to
in front of my son's face today.
Well I was facing,
I was at the counter,
I was at the counter and he walked up behind me and I felt his head nudge.
His height is like right at my butt cheeks and I had a far,
so I just let it go to like joke with him.
Did he laugh?
I don't know.
He was just like,
he was like,
did he smell it?
It smelled bad.
I don't know.
It wasn't a crazy fart.
It was just
no,
what now?
Do you remember her first part?
No,
I don't remember.
I don't remember the first one.
I think I stole too much thunder with mine for my memory.
But then I was thankful that we had broken that.
How do you hide that in a relationship with somebody?
Well,
there's still a thing.
I mean,
I think it's not just,
just because he farted her in a hand.
I think that doesn't necessarily,
I mean,
you know,
make a,
create a safe space for you to far yet because sir,
no,
because of,
you know,
there's these,
there's these gender issues about like,
you know,
guys can fart on hands,
but you know,
girls can't farm guy.
And I'm like,
I'm a guy.
I don't know.
I didn't know if you had a different pronoun or whatever.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
No,
I mean it wasn't like farting.
I actually enjoy it and it's fine.
So it was good.
Yeah.
Uh,
and uh,
you know,
and by the way,
you guys started dating in 2005,
right?
Yeah.
And I met you guys in 2007.
Yes,
oftentimes there's in September,
2007 so it's been just about 10 years.
10 year anniversary.
She kept studying together.
Yeah.
It's so much fun with you.
We went to a museum,
we went to,
we went to the Capitol Capitol
Capitol.
I think that's where it was.
It wasn't a museum.
It was a capital and it was,
we saw a painting of George Bush.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
That was fun.
That was French.
Yeah.
And your pants were open.
My parents
ever do things like that on the road since like that's probably the only time
I did cap city with you.
They booked me the next year to headline it.
Yeah.
And then he didn't book me again for like five years.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And I was like,
why can't
I was,
I was doing that club regularly for a little while and then uh,
you know,
stop doing it.
But do you still work the road at all?
I don't like to do club weeks anymore,
you know?
Yeah.
And I have it.
I don't understand why.
Cause it's always well,
yeah.
No,
I prefer to just get everyone coming in.
Yeah,
exactly.
Of course I do.
You remember the one show we had?
Uh,
there was one really bad show.
That one.
Yeah,
you did fine,
but it was a packed crowd.
There was a game the next day I guess.
And people weren't town for the game.
I think I made a college game.
I have to give you a lot of credit.
I have to give you a lot of credit because you did this thing where like you
were an wavering with your set like you did well.
You got to commit.
Well yeah.
You did what you had say people were leaving.
Yeah.
Like throughout the show cause and not just leaving but leaving in anger like so
angry and I was like,
man,
this is fucking on comfortable.
Yeah.
I think it was the Friday early show.
It might've been.
It was the fullest show of the week.
Yeah.
It was totally packed.
Sold out I think.
And for the whole 45 minutes.
You know what's interesting is like so many people that were like not into this
show.
Let's say half of them were like,
just the fuck the one guy left.
I remember it cause I was in uh,
in the lobby.
He goes,
that guy's an asshole.
Like he was angry about his set,
which,
and not even at like he's provoking him.
Like you weren't like saying something to,
to anger him.
He was just upset about it.
You did your,
the next day you did the exact like,
you know,
the same set and you killed.
Yeah.
And it was all the rest of the week was fine.
But I meant like the like what I remember it was like the VA like who knows what
will happen.
Saturday early show was still a full,
full,
pretty full house.
Yeah.
Did the same thing.
It just,
that,
that was just remember that one,
just that one show and I do recall you're doing fine.
I think are doing well,
you know,
and uh,
and yeah,
actually I'm almost certain you did very well.
He probably,
I think you probably killed,
which didn't hurt help me,
but well for that,
you know,
who was to know that that show was going to be such a bad show for me.
But yeah,
there were walkouts definitely.
Like at least a third of the crowd walked out.
But it's so funny that you know that people can get upset at different things
because you weren't like,
uh,
you know,
fuck your way of thinking.
I never,
I,
I don't want to be a fan.
I never named to be an offensive comedian actually.
Interesting how,
first of all it was a wonderful lesson cause I was there for that show and I was
just like dipping my toe into being a,
being a feature act and the watch you commit and really be like,
Nope,
this is the act.
And I know as a first time I'd seen anybody really do that and I was like,
that's fucking awesome.
And it just goes to show how different audiences are our suck.
Like,
yeah,
like you said the next night,
it was fantastic and you killed it and then just this particular audience is not
into it and has nothing to do with you.
Yeah.
And they were like,
you know what's funny is that they were angry.
Like a lot of that,
I can't speak for all of them.
A lot of them were angry
at his commitment to what he was doing.
They weren't mad at like,
you know,
you said I'm gonna take your guns away.
Or like it wasn't like,
oh politics.
They were just mad at like,
he's still doing this.
So funny still doing it.
And yet I recall I actually somehow sold a tee shirt that show for some reason
someone bought a tee shirt and then the next show or maybe the next night had a
really strong staff and it didn't it all by,
it was more not anything that fuck with you at all.
Like when you're sitting in your hotel room.
That set did make me think,
could I,
at that point I thought I had a good headlining set that was kind of full proof,
you know?
And then that made me think,
oh,
I guess it's not foolproof,
you know,
or something.
And I was,
I thought,
and I'm always strive to try to actually make a great set that,
that I do feel there's a responsibility when headlining a show to do a good job,
you know,
it was one of the worst reactions I've ever seen to a headlining set.
Do you know whose was worse?
Mine because I got booed off stage a few years later.
I,
well I not a headlining set.
I've got,
I've got booed off stage when I was opening.
And you have like in the more,
in the past before that you thought about your set?
When I was a bombing.
So wait,
hold on,
hold on.
Let's,
sorry,
I don't mean it to take that away.
You've got booed as a headlining sets where Winnepeg when a few years ago,
really few years ago.
Where are you getting political or something?
Um,
no,
I uh,
what did you do?
You fart on someone's hand.
I just talked shit to somebody early on who was talking.
Okay.
So it was because of a heckler incident or something.
Interesting.
It unraveled.
Wow.
But I'm saying I tried to go into the act basically like,
hey,
why don't you shut the fuck up and then go back to doing stand up.
And they were just,
they just,
wow.
How did that make you feel?
Actually that was just a few years ago.
That was crazy,
man.
That was nuts.
I really did think about your set.
Oh really?
Yes.
Because I remembered like doing things like act,
I would,
I was like,
I would act like the room wasn't falling apart.
It was falling apart.
Like screaming.
People were like,
yeah.
And I would be like,
so the other day and you just hear murmuring and talking and stuff.
I would try to do,
cause I,
yeah,
it's very hard to focus.
Yeah.
I was saying like it's crazy sense.
No,
I've had some set,
some sets like that where it's just,
I mean it's actually pretty like seldom,
you know?
I mean I've only like,
I can count how many
one hand,
but like sets where you're,
you have to do full hour and you're like trying to,
you know,
you're just hearing people talking or just,
it's so weird.
It's such a surreal thing.
So hard.
You almost think that that doesn't happen,
you know?
But it does.
And you know what can be like the,
for me,
like this is separate let's say from,
we're talking about like catastrophic stuff,
but like when you're,
let's say 99% of the room is,
is good and you're doing your,
you're
talking about something and you hear one table,
like what if we go over it over to Jennifer is later and then I'll pick her up
and then we can pick up and you start hearing that.
Yeah.
And you're like,
your train of thought really annoying.
You want to go like,
hey man.
And then they're like,
well,
I'm just like saying something.
You're like,
I know,
but I can't hear my own thoughts because I keep hearing you talk about going to
Jennifer.
Totally,
totally.
It's,
yeah,
it's really just a huge distraction.
Yeah.
But you guys know,
just do you just do like one night somewhere,
right?
A lot of times.
Yeah.
I mean that's what I try to do now is just do one night in the city.
We have all the fans coming to one of the yeah,
that's the way to go.
Where are you going anywhere?
Uh,
no,
I don't have anything major coming up.
I mean,
yeah.
No,
nothing major coming up.
But,
um,
let's see.
Let's show Brent.
Um,
let's see if he's interested in eating a bowl of something.
Okay.
We'll see if,
uh,
you want to come over later?
I think this is Charlie honey.
June.
Yeah,
that's Charlie.
Oh my God.
Get your passenger son of a bitch.
Dammit.
Dirty Bitch.
Now.
Fuck.
You guys are showing good.
Oh,
Java.
Is that Charlie?
Oh.
Dirty son of a calm down layer for myself,
for moose soup.
Moose.
It.
What do you think that lady looks like?
Yeah.
Describe her.
Oh,
you didn't give was a lady.
I thought it was a man.
That guy first year voice.
No.
Yeah,
I thought that was a man.
I know you did.
I swear I thought that was a man.
Really?
Yeah.
You didn't have really,
it's definitely a woman.
No,
I think it's a man actually listen to the voice.
Yeah.
You guys come down here after I got moved soup and everything.
Yeah,
no.
Right.
You guys are doing good.
Wait.
Okay.
I guess now that you're mentioning you on video
that it's a woman seeing it now as a woman I guess.
But I was thinking a man the whole time.
That was some man.
Yeah.
Some guy,
some guy.
Interesting take.
I mean look,
we're open to non binaries.
That's true.
I mean,
did you picture a pronoun a healthy man or no?
Okay.
No,
no I didn't.
He wasn't healthy.
You know,
I thought of him as Kinda thick,
you know,
kind of,
kind of scraggly,
scraggly,
thick,
scraggly thick,
you know,
kind of Wa.
Yeah.
It kinda messy.
You know,
kind of sloppy,
sloppy,
thick.
Yeah.
These beaten all that Moose suit.
Right here.
That moves kind of smooth.
Soup says soupy look.
Moosey Luke Blue Look.
Oh,
there's more,
wait,
hold on.
Back Up.
Yeah.
Is this somebody you know?
No.
Okay.
I should though.
I like her.
I mean we,
we assumed big tits.
Lots of has had lots of sex.
Lots of cigarette.
Yeah.
But mostly cigarettes.
Cigarettes for sure.
Yeah.
You know what?
Never mind.
It kind of reminds me of,
is that that Rhubarb Rhubarb Lady?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We played her stealing the rhubarb.
Yeah.
She sounds like that.
You remember the Rhubarb Lady?
I don't remember the rhubarb laid out.
No,
I would say that on this show years ago.
Yeah.
It's an old clip.
It's an old viral clip.
This lady was stealing rhubarb and sounds very similar to that,
but although her voice is higher pitch,
and I guess that's why I thought it was my man.
A man I thought was just
pitch man.
Fucking hell.
Somebody,
why don't you take some,
grow your home.
Now you're fucking property.
Go somewhere else.
Right.
And everybody's fucking visit,
visit,
whatever the bitch
name on it.
Please.
Your name
sound like an angry or a version of what?
This side of yeah,
that's a little younger.
Yeah,
it's a younger,
so what I'm saying?
No,
that's the female voice.
Then the other one is the,
uh,
you know why?
Because this is Trish as a young Trish
distro shout or per month.
Oh yeah.
It's a mature as mature blossom.
That's true.
Voice got deeper with the cigarettes too.
And it's like,
it's like she hit puberty.
Yeah.
Something like that one.
That was like,
that was a young,
that was the young one.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
man,
I'm why glad you guys fart though,
you know?
That's good.
Yeah.
We definitely apartment.
That's how we like to Fart.
I can't believe you have a girlfriend two years now.
Yeah.
That's how infrequently I see you.
Well I,
you guys have almost a two year old kid.
That's true.
And I don't think I,
I saw you at the,
I saw you was comp.
Oh really?
I know at the comedy store recently.
Very recently.
You did?
Yeah.
You can come talk to me.
Yeah,
we did.
we did talk.
We talked.
Yeah.
Really?
You know the parking lot?
No.
In the room.
Yeah,
we did.
God,
Dad,
you don't remember.
I just cut off for five days.
You grabbed my hand.
You farted on it.
Yeah.
Brand.
Do you think you'll ever get married or you,
the marrying kind of would like to,
I'd like to have a family.
I'd like to be,
I,
you guys have,
you guys kind of have what I want right now.
You have your starting a family.
I don't know if you're trying to go for another,
but you know and you've got to have a house here.
I have a suburban area.
Not under the dogs.
We saw it.
Yeah.
No,
I don't do that.
The animals.
Nah,
Nah.
Don't fuck with them.
Nah,
that's not for me.
You know what I love about you and your act by the way,
he has a special,
what's the name of your special on appealing to the mainstream?
Appealing to the mainstream.
And you have this great bit about being a teacher in Oakland and the black
students call you mister pants.
I don't,
I don't specify that they're black,
but they sound,
you could say they could be,
they could be white,
they could be Indian.
That's true.
Urbanites there's just Oakland kids,
you know,
pants could be,
hey,
look,
grant granted definitely there were a lot of black kids that I substitute taught
one.
Oh really,
really crazy.
There were Indians to Indians.
That's a crazy job.
That's,
that's gotta be.
Yeah.
No,
they were,
they were.
Yeah,
they were tough kids.
They were,
I mean,
it was tough.
It was,
it,
uh,
made me a tough person.
Kind of made me a better comedian actually.
Right.
Yeah,
for sure.
Actually,
a lot of the stuff in that special,
a lot of it's older material and a lot of that stuff I was doing that week that
we met in Austin,
you know?
Yeah.
You from California,
can you tell?
Oh,
yeah,
yeah.
That's,
yeah,
me all three.
Like your black voices on fleek?
I would say.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess,
thank you.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't necessarily,
uh,
you think they sound black specifically?
I'd say you do a really good black dude.
Wait,
you're trying to suggest that anyone would believe that then it's the pants.
Kids are not black.
Well,
they might not be,
you know,
they could be,
it could be anything.
It could just be there's just urbanites Indians.
Okay.
No
talking,
not black.
It's really funny.
I would love for people to,
well,
here's the thing,
but the special is there is no,
this is kind of like not even on a,
I think you can get something out of it that you get more if you pay close
attention.
I think there's more to get out of it than just the laughs.
Oh Geez.
I don't know what to,
I don't know.
I just,
I don't want to say much more,
but just that's the thing is if you embraced it,
embrace it fully,
and I think those,
there's more to it than I think.
I think you're very layered and,
and I think that's accurate.
I want people to,
I just feel like people haven't been,
I haven't really heard much talk of,
uh,
the,
what you can get out of it.
There's more to get out of it.
I don't want to much more,
more teasing I think on Seeso.
Yeah.
And we'll see.
Hopefully appealing to the mainstream CSO.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
That's how I do
it,
man.
This is a healthy way,
if me is way more how they use in the backwoods,
the White House,
the Garcia,
beggars,
you know what I mean?
All that type of shit that join the broad life man for,
for me,
we're trying to get you out of the environment.
That's all we smoking for now.
Almost gonna be number rocky for me now.
I would dabble in the,
you know what I mean?
And the swishes and shit like that,
you know,
every once in a while you coming to spice it up a little bit,
cause you already know,
you know what I mean?
Just switch a girl.
You feel me?
You got to spice it up a little bit.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You gotta be willing to go out of your comfort zone.
So you know what I mean?
And pressure girl and pressed the mother fucking galaxy.
You feel me?
So I got a smoke blunt
so I feel like he hit you feel me?
Definitely not.
Maybe you know what I'm saying that I missed,
but you know what I mean?
Hit the TRIFECTA.
Is West Coast?
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
West Coast Guy.
Yeah.
What's the deal?
What's the,
I guess I could,
I could hear that.
I can hear the east coast accent when I hear urban voices,
I can hear the east coast,
but I guess maybe because I'm from the west coast,
maybe that's it.
I,
it sounds just
core once when,
when the way that like Carla said,
oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
very like distinct.
so when they say like upper here,
you know her,
you know,
and they say here her like,
do you think that is the Westcott her would be like,
that's like a southern,
southern that southern or something.
Yeah.
I really want to get,
I want to see you guys.
I'll show it to you guys after the recording,
the new hotline videos.
Oh really?
Cool.
Vietnam you have them?
I have access to.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
one of them is like a,
one of them is that you can call different dads and uh,
like if you're looking like if you need discipline or you need advice,
you know,
it's like a dad hotline,
you know?
Um,
and another one is this,
oh,
this one's a hunk hotline.
It's for ladies only if you want to call it.
But that's all I'll say.
But there's more to it than that.
I feel like.
I feel like,
you know those,
the,
that California Lingo and you're saying that you like,
you're like,
I don't know
for registered.
No,
what I'm saying is that I can't distinguish that if their west coast,
because I'm,
I guess because that's normal.
Like that just sounds normal where it jumps out to me more if it's east coast or
southern,
I guess.
You know,
I had noticed when I was in Miami,
it was funny,
it was like they have such a distinct accent.
Locals.
Oh,
locals just speaking English like no,
regardless of that,
they,
they basically sound like they learned English after they learned another
language.
Um,
you know,
a huge obvious Spanish,
but these are non bilingual people speaking English.
That's funny.
And so,
and you're like,
your accent's crazy.
And they're like,
what accent?
Like what?
They go,
you have an accent.
And I go,
I have a pretty nondescript accent when I speak.
And they were like,
oh no,
your accent is heavy.
I'm like,
wow.
Yeah.
It's the same idea so much.
Well there's also people who there's like,
you know,
Hispanic people in Los Angeles who speak Spanish,
but they do have some kind of accent that is,
that sounds like a Hispanic accent.
Right,
right,
right.
I don't even speak Spanish dog.
Yeah.
Or something.
You know,
cause they,
it's just a,
or the,
I remember in San Francisco there's people who have Chinese accidents,
but they're from,
I dunno,
maybe they do you speak Chinese,
but they were,
they,
they were from San Francisco,
born and raised and they've got an accent.
There was a dude in Hong Kong who lives there now who was raised,
he was born and raised in New York City,
but in like a hardcore,
you know,
insulated Chinatown neighborhood.
So he speaks English with a heavy,
heavy accent.
Yeah.
And his Cantonese is just,
okay.
Ah,
yeah.
Right,
exactly.
He's like,
his primary language is English,
but it's,
it's,
I mean when you hear him speak,
you'd be like,
you would be like,
oh,
you know,
you would like all this guy learned English.
Do you remember when we were at that restaurant and we saw that white guy at
that Chinese wedding?
Yes.
It's like fully spittin like real dog Chinese.
And even had like the posturing,
like he was talking to like five older Chinese guys,
like,
you know,
though,
the total posturing and right.
This kid was like 30 and he mannerisms accent like totally down.
Rad.
Well,
I went to China a couple of years ago and uh,
met up with this guy who was like that as a white guy from Seattle.
And when he started talking Chinese,
it was like,
it didn't seem like it was coming out of his mouth.
It was like,
seemed like it was like he's playing a tape or something.
It's just crazy.
He had the all the mannerisms down just like that.
And that was the way to do it.
My sister and I,
we went together.
I was doing shows actually in part of the trip,
but they,
uh,
we went,
we every where we ate was so bad.
We got the wrong,
we didn't know we even know what to order.
We just pointed at stuff and just said something at the menu and got just like
an ear soup or something like that.
Like a soup just with ears,
Moose,
Moose suit.
It was moose here soup.
And I just want to come down for Chinese Moose to plater.
Yeah.
And um,
but then when we went to this restaurant with this guy,
it was the best Chinese meal I've ever had.
He knew how to do it,
but,
um,
I had this idea for a,
I dunno,
a series or something,
um,
about a guy who's,
he's white and he's as a baby,
he's adopted by Chinese people and they bring them to China and they raised them
in China fully.
And so he doesn't even speak.
He speaks really poor English and he speaks fluent Chinese,
but he's white and he has an accent and stuff.
And then he goes back to the United States to kind of find his routes and stuff.
And um,
but he has this Chinese accent and everyone thinks that he's making,
he's uh,
yeah,
he's making fun of Chinese people or something,
but that's actually how he taught.
Sure.
Now,
oh,
have you ever heard of foreign accent syndrome?
No.
Where people wake up one day and they just have like a crazy
training.
Exactly.
Like a,
have a knot.
I surely heard the,
my voice in the conversation nearly for Ya know that ladies
white,
she's English.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
She just wakes up and has an attic.
Well,
they usually,
it's prompted by some type of head trauma.
Yeah.
Okay.
So these,
uh,
people have,
have some type of accident,
something that affects the brain usually that,
um,
then gives them a foreign accent but not,
you know,
your language abilities.
Like you,
you're,
you're speaking your native language but with a foreign accent.
Yeah.
But wait,
wait,
but is it like she,
she's adopting something or like she'd adopting the Anat in voluntarily adopting
a Chinese accent or something.
She,
yeah.
Or is it that it just,
she sounded kind of weird that it sounds like a Chinese Zach?
Well,
that's an interesting question,
but they have,
I mean there's,
there's a number of cases that have it throughout the world in the,
in those stuff that we've looked up where there,
there's just not enough information to know exactly what's going on.
Like they know there's,
there's been one where they were like,
oh,
this lady's just fucking with people.
Like it was a hoax.
But there's ladies like this lady has,
you know,
she's been doing it for like at this point,
like five,
six years.
And it was,
she hasn't key play it again.
Yeah.
And her grammars and correct.
Which is interesting.
I have a knot.
I challis hide the my voice in the conversation for nearly four year now.
That's interesting cause I was thinking,
I was wondering if it was just that the head trauma or whatever it was affected
her speech and it happens to sound like a foreigner or if it's like some kind of
weird thing where the brain is taking from an accident that she's heard doing
that.
I mean it sounds distinctly like an Asian.
Yeah,
it does.
Yeah.
Accent.
Oh my God.
This actually,
but then again,
you know,
sometimes people want their desk when they're death.
Yeah.
They sound French.
Kind of.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
How do blind people wipe?
Have you ever thought about
like do you,
how do you think a blind person,
no,
I mean it's time to stop all of that that we had.
We had a very deep conversation last time I was here,
not at this specific location,
but on this show about wiping techniques and stuff.
And you know,
for me,
right,
you showed,
I think I used to have a joke about that.
I don't just wipe until you,
you can't see that the poo on the tissue,
but I wipe until you can't smell the anything on the tissue interest.
It's like not even,
cause sometimes you can't see it,
but you might be able to smell something that you always know your paper.
Well,
I don't really do such a thing as much anymore,
but if I can as much meaning to I did it.
I used this,
definitely smell the paper.
I wouldn't get that close though,
but I would,
if I could smell it from here,
know then that would be,
but I don't actually come to think of it.
I probably don't smell the tissue really anymore.
But I did used to do that though.
Have you ever taken a messy brown and then like,
you know when you keep wiping and wiping and wiping and then the rest,
right?
Yes.
Infinite life.
Now have you ever gone to shower to get rid of the infinite pill?
No.
I just,
I kinda just keep going.
Even though it takes a really long time.
I keep going until it's finally ends.
Even though that sometimes,
well,
you know why that's because blood is starting to mix in with it because you've
wiped so much that it started to bleed.
And so I feel like we talked about this last time I,
yeah,
you keep wiping.
It's going to eventually you start,
it starts showing up because of the blood and I don't know why.
Cause you already know.
Those are all the categories represented in that one clip we'd like to track.
That was good.
But yeah.
How,
how do blind people finish though?
They said that they're,
the,
the email that we got was that when like you already know about when one of your
senses goes,
others heightens that,
that they pick up that your,
your sense of touch is so heightened at that point that what you feel also
dictates,
yeah,
no,
there's no resistance and that means that it's a smooth,
clean lie.
I don't,
I,
you know what,
it really makes me start to think that maybe,
well I don't want to say anything,
but I don't know.
It makes me start to not trust blind people.
Hypocrite.
Because Christina as much,
here we go.
I got an email.
I had been listening to old episodes and something from episode three 70 stood
out to personality champ.
Tom was playing a song that had Christina talking about being down to prove
she's the water champ.
Yet in recent weeks,
she declined to approve it as if it was beneath her.
This true,
this proves to me not only was Tom a true champion as he's willing to defend his
title like a professional,
but Christina is a choppy,
changey hypocrite and capable of being champion at anything.
Actually,
I take that back that she is clearly the hypocrite.
Champ.
I'm reigns as the water posture and personality champ.
Meanwhile,
Christina is simply a second grade moose soup eating liar from Troy in New
Zealand.
Why does choppy Chang mean anyway?
How racist is that?
I don't know.
I don't let the records show Yana
currently drinking glass of water.
Tom,
where's your water in this episode?
It's not because you're drinking soda via with fake sugar in it.
As we had the water expert in here and he couldn't even drink that,
he spit it out.
Oh,
the wood.
The guy who was the race start,
ray and stark bar.
There was a guy at the,
uh,
I don't know,
I was like ray and stark bars.
Is that like the Los Angeles County Museum of Art?
There's a restaurant there.
Mark,
I think his name is Martin [inaudible] work anymore and maybe it was working.
He's a water Somalia Patina.
Oh yeah.
I kind of,
I talked to him myself.
You talked about,
uh,
did you,
do you bring in the different waters and you to try there?
We've tried like six or from water.
Some of you I tried,
I tried three when I was with him as fascinating guy.
Yeah.
It's really interesting.
He just goes to different needs.
Something,
excuse me again,
just goes to different cities and he,
um,
wait,
should we break,
write down?
we'd go to different cities and he always like tries to tap just to see what it
tastes like.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We learned so much.
That episode you tried that really heavy on the mineral wine was like kind of
salty,
kind of.
Yeah.
Did he give you that whitewash?
That one.
That was like a Whitewater,
oh,
it's a full thing.
It was a full thing.
Everything cool guys pricing.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
By the way,
I don't want to,
I hope that I don't want any blind listeners to be offended about what I was
saying.
I was just thinking you,
you bring up an interesting point about that and uh,
I'm sure there's a way,
and I'm sure they'd probably just use a lot of water and kind of just hope for
the best kind of yeah.
If you know what I mean or whatever.
Well,
because then the infinite wipes,
I mean you walk around with leaky,
but all day long,
so you just wiping your butt all day when you have an infinite loop.
Got a pool.
Um,
tell me the name again of the special appealing to the mainstream.
The mainstream.
He's,
here's a cut from appealing to mainstream Brenton white box CSOS special.
Oh,
I,
because y'all allowed it baby to wake me up that damn door.
Okay.
I don't have to watch no lane.
So she actually,
she's making a great point.
Hmm.
She was woken up by somebody who's letting their kid play video at volume with
no headphones negative,
which is one of my personally I think that's a incredibly rude yeah.
And forget about,
she is saying like,
I'm not getting to sleep because you're letting your kid go and fucking play
shit.
Um,
but no,
I agree.
I totally agree.
Yeah.
Well y'all got this fall.
Nice.
China woke me up with the Scooby Doo.
See it?
Yeah.
I guess my,
I guess my approach would have been a little different though,
you know?
Oh well I probably would have just said,
um,
excuse me,
can you turn,
can you not have the volume on on this because he's seen you please cause not
have my mind.
Cause then I like,
yeah,
the flight attendants eventually get yeah.
This fucking baby.
A black day.
Yeah.
That would have
cut the damn noise because you can get an antibody us and getting cooked.
He's saying cause too.
Yeah.
He said,
she said anybody can get,
was this like a family reunion on the plane?
Sparkling and then
letting the baby wake up.
Everybody would just go,
the dude's shit.
I don't give a fuck.
She's right.
That is disrespectful as hell.
One time Tom and I were at a really fancy,
we were really fancy restaurant for dinner.
Yeah.
And if you remember,
and there was a family and the baby had the IPAD,
which is fine,
but it was full volume.
Just boop,
boop.
All adults.
Why is it baby up?
It's late anyways.
The baby should be in bed.
Yeah,
and playing stupid fucking IPAD.
That's so obvious.
People,
not that it's wrong.
Give your baby and iPad.
I don't care about that.
But then give the kid I what does everyone have to hear the earphones?
What an earbud sorry.
I would just say this is what I would do.
I would say,
like I said,
you know,
would say,
can you turn it down?
Can you turn off the volume please?
Yeah.
And then if they didn't do it,
then I would call it flight attendant and say,
yeah,
she's right.
She's not turning it off.
Follow the rules.
His baby won't be on Google.
We do see it
that day.
The,
hey,
the baby had to go through down,
let me tell you what the baby had to go prove it out with wellcare batty Odo
meal.
But this tool,
oh the computer now walking through here and I went out on what region is in.
I hear that.
I'm sorry,
my bad baby seen him with the little computer
computer.
I like that the ladies like I'm like she's so first of all she's such in Zombie
land.
Who knows that this is the third leg of her trip.
But like ignores all noise anyways is I didn't hear,
did you hear it?
She's like yeah.
Anything.
Yeah.
Body of woke me up with this tool.
We do shit now walking through shit out on here.
That's south.
Did not hear that.
I'm sorry.
Ah,
you heard that shit bitch.
She's right.
She did hear that Shit.
You heard that cause yeah cause cause you,
she heard that.
She heard that.
I don't know what to tell you where I need to know.
It's no,
it's no,
it's no worries.
Sorry that lag out.
I gotta be sorry.
He's parents depending on his fault.
I'm just jelly.
You know,
this shit was wrong.
It was the parents fault.
Okay.
Is kind of calming down though.
She actually lives,
she's because she,
she's actually,
it's,
it's getting less emotional and more logical.
Yeah.
And cause she wrapped it on emotion.
Then it switched over to logic and her logic is correct here.
Logic is correct.
She calmed down and he's still making the,
she knows she's right.
Yeah.
Cause cause cause yeah,
everybody can get it.
Would you rather be on the receiving end of her lecturing you like that or be
retarded?
Oh,
um,
sure.
Think.
Do you think you'd know you're retarded?
Right,
right,
right.
I guess I'd rather be on the receiving end because I think I'd actually enjoy it
actually to some degree getting yelled at being called because,
and you'd have a new five minutes for sure that,
that'll be my new special.
What would it be called?
Appealing.
Appealing to the south because the south coast,
every link to the,
because everyone can get it.
That would be the name of the special cause that's what she said.
Everyone can get it.
Well she does.
Oh yeah.
It kind of like it falls in line with appealing to the mainstream.
I mean everyone can get it.
Everyone.
Everyone yet it cuts because,
yeah.
Well what about,
what if it was just called because
um,
the rather be retarded or when you do your act it's like the hackiest who's like
dead that we can make fun of.
Um,
it's all like in 1950 was alive.
Do you guys ever talk crap about comedians?
Pretty much.
It's like the worst act ever.
It's basically everything that you hate,
but you have to do the act.
You have to think.
Trying to think of like a hack,
like someone who's dead,
who's hacked,
like you've got like prior Carlin,
but it's just a cheesy puppets explosions.
It's magic.
That all sounds good to me.
That is not puppets.
Puppets.
I'm sure if puppets,
I don't do puppets,
but I mean if I could do puppets and they were cool,
I would do,
yeah.
Cool locations,
I would do that.
Would you rather I do explosions.
There are explosions in my special actually appealing to the mainstream.
There is definitely an explosion explosion,
so
it's good though.
He retarded or have a hacky Yak or do the worst possible,
like whatever you hate,
whoever you hate in comedy.
Well I'd probably do that.
Right.
Versus being retired.
I wouldn't,
would I?
Well hold on.
I mean I guess the question is,
is what I realized it was bad,
but yes,
you actively have to do it.
Like I'm me and I have to do this act and you know it goes in here already are
retarded by the way.
You're fucking breaking this down.
It goes against kind of hard or sensibilities and you're going up every night
and you're doing these shit cans.
Definitely hard to do the act and you can't do anything that you believe is
funny.
You have to do like this act is what I'm saying and I don't realize I'm
retarded.
Retarded.
That's the biggest question that we have on the show.
Is that do retarded people know they're retarded?
No,
I think about that too sometimes.
Well,
my brother had this thought,
this idea that of he had this idea of like a,
maybe a movie even about a retarded person who knew they were retarded and you
know,
just didn't,
didn't like it.
You know,
they wish they were smarter,
they wish they weren't retarded and they,
and that that was like a thing they had to come to terms with.
You know,
he had this image of a guy just looking up at the sky going,
why,
you know,
he was retarded and stuff.
Or was it a comedy or was it more like a drama?
Like a drama,
you know,
serious like a serious movie about someone who is mentally challenging and is
aware of it though.
Oh that's right.
Okay.
So let's say,
and in your world you were aware of it.
Yeah,
that's hard.
It's hard.
All your creativity is stifled basically.
Cause you have to do an act that you don't believe.
Let me ask you this,
do I make money as this hacky comedian?
Yes.
I probably would do this well,
so I can't answer this.
I would say this,
I'd probably pick the hacky thing because at least I can provide a life for my
family or my kids or something,
you know?
But you can be the retarded comic.
That's thing doing his own thing,
doing what he wants to be.
He can be a retarded artist artist.
You can be uh,
you know,
at least have integrity.
You can be retired and have integrity or be a hack and
so you can actually provide for your family too is retarded.
But I guess I've,
I guess I value connecting to people on a non retarded level,
you know what I mean?
And I don't mean that in any kind of offensive way or anything,
but just,
you know,
like being able to connect to people in an sort of intellectual way.
I value that.
I guess I value that,
but it'd be very alone.
Okay.
What about you guys?
What do you do?
Being a hack or being retarded or,
and also back to,
but I have a son,
I have a son,
so I couldn't take care of my son if I were retarded.
So I'd have to always choose the other thing.
Yeah.
I guess I don't want to have someone take care of me.
Then again,
actually getting taken care of could be fun.
It was like,
oh,
I want to be retired at hands down.
It would be so liberating if no responsibility family and it's different.
Different.
Well,
if I wasn't,
I guess if I was retarded,
I wouldn't care about having a family maybe as much or you do care.
I am aware of it.
Right.
I'm aware of being retarded.
It's hard.
It's really hard.
Just so much more than I wanted.
I did this question,
uh,
what was the other question was where the w would you rather,
I don't remember.
Something about poo or something.
I'd go retarded.
So he,
does he go retarded?
He's retarded over eating Chinese or Asian really would rather be retarded than
eat Asian food.
Gosh,
really?
Yeah.
I know that your dad wipes from back to front.
Does he was down.
He wipes down.
That's right.
I remember that from last time.
That's good,
man.
Yeah.
Has Your Dad ever been on the show live?
No.
He's called in a bunch.
Your Dad's in Florida,
right?
Yeah,
it's called a bunch of times.
We've called him.
He sat here and did an interview.
Well,
you know,
I've talked to them and recorded it and then play the audio later.
That's the extent of it.
Um,
you,
what about you?
You retarded?
I am.
I would go retired.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Both the Oh yeah,
no,
you can,
I want to take care of her.
Can't be retarded.
What does he could though if I could,
I,
I my my mental capacity is all I have.
Well wait,
what if you're,
what if,
yeah.
What if your son was retarded to therefore as a retired person who could take
care of them?
That's interesting.
But I don't know.
I don't think you could.
Honestly,
I know I can't be retarded caregiver as the crop Tory Center,
the badger shown above and red is concerned with hearing,
oh,
we're having too much fun shown here on the outer surface of the brain.
Whenever we get too excited,
lies within the temporal lobe is found within the brain.
The cerebral cortex on both sides of the kind.
Kinda interesting.
Yeah.
This one's the hosting Cory pathways begin in the nerve fibers of the Oregon of
core team in the inner ear.
Now it's still,
see how it changed,
right?
It's like cleanses the palate.
Yeah.
You're like,
oh,
okay.
I can make a boring sorbet.
Yeah.
That's Kinda cool actually.
Born.
That's what we do.
There's a,
a big words,
Christina remix here.
Do you want,
I don't want to hear it.
No,
it's a big world.
It's a what?
Yeah.
I want to know Brandon,
do you,
uh,
do you want me to skip it?
Well,
you've teased it to the audience.
Now we have to play me.
It's in my,
I thought you saw it.
I mean,
it's in solid.
Wait,
what?
I'm just doing the email solid.
There's people that go,
I thought I saw it.
Saw it.
You saw it that people make songs from the show a lot.
Oh yes.
I'm not going to say the n word anymore because I don't want the songs to come
on.
Oh,
you said that.
Wait,
were you saying the n word a lot or something?
No,
I give it to you.
Hey,
good,
good.
Why would you say that it's a guy,
not a girl.
It's a damn
Nigga.
Nigga,
Yeah.
Potato Patato.
You know what I mean?
I don't think out Nigga,
Nigga dead moose soup is like the running again.
Yeah.
Also could retarded people
racist.
Yeah,
of course.
And then obviously returning to people.
Yes.
They can be racist.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Dirty.
There you go.
Thanks.
I was reading an email from us and Dan made that.
Thank you.
[inaudible] cool.
And in the email it said the n word and so yeah,
that's whenever I say the n word on the show,
it gets remixed and she was reading something that said it and then I don't just
say it.
Oh yeah,
no,
there's a context for it.
I don't,
I don't know.
I approve [inaudible] you made 800 party line.
Jesus.
Yeah,
no,
there's a context for any,
I mean there's a safe context.
Anything.
That's why,
I mean there's always like,
people sometimes say that you can't say certain things or certain things are
completely off limits,
but that there's,
there's always some kind of exception exception or some sort of context where
you can,
you can say anything Nice,
you know?
Yeah.
Um,
especially if you're quoting something or reading something.
Sorry.
Yeah,
of course.
What else do you got there,
Tommy?
Um,
I got,
uh,
well I have a,
another song that we'll,
we'll we'll close with a,
okay.
We did the uh,
oh,
there's a sperm extractor machine that's new.
I don't know.
Brent will use
this unusual machine aims to take the embarrassment out of sperm donation called
the sperm extraction.
It was devised by doing [inaudible] Jang,
one of China's Django San way medical science.
I like how you're more embarrassing than just jerking it,
isn't it?
I mean the thing is that it's like,
it's an ATM basically designed with a hole in it that you just,
what kind of like we talked,
we've talked about like if there was like a suck machine and guys would just
walk up to it.
I've never talked about that with you.
Yeah,
we did.
Nope,
that's not right.
We've talked about come gum and having gum sperm and then they also says that
people,
but then you were like,
oh,
I had this other thing.
Remember you,
you brought up the pump station.
Okay.
That's what this is the I you just said I've never thought of that.
It's not the sucking,
I didn't say there was a Dick Sucking station.
It's a pump,
that pump station where you could go and get different guys to Jews in your
mouth.
Okay,
well I'm thinking a little differently.
I'm thinking like shots of comm guys walk around with poison in them all the
time.
Right.
And it'd be great if you're just walking around like full of rage and they're
like,
dude,
just walk up to that machine and you go,
I mean,
you're right.
You're done.
You're like,
it's quick.
Yeah.
Uh Huh.
And it services society.
Yeah,
like it clean.
It's clean,
right?
You're just like,
yeah.
How does it clean itself?
I don't know how clear.
Here's what else I want to know.
You know when she know and she keeps sucking and you're like,
Ooh,
like what if this thing keeps going and you're like,
stop stops.
Is there a stop button?
Like is there an emergency stop like on a treadmill where you pull off and
you're like,
oh shit,
I fell off this thing.
Like how does,
that's a real issue because he didn't want to keep,
you can just pull your wiener out.
No,
cause it looks like,
it looks like it gets pretty tight on you.
Yeah.
She didn't 19 teens.
It is shut down.
Hospitals mostly use.
It's cool that that guy kind of like is the guy behind it,
you know?
He seems so,
you know the average.
I know.
Just like Nice Guy and sealed.
Sealed as to me.
It's political demands.
Excuse,
walk up to that president buttons.
But she's also using a sperm.
It's supposed to be outside though.
Huh?
Looks like it's just enough.
It looks like it's in,
it sounds like it's in the hall.
Like a hallway of a mall or you will put your Dick in this real quick.
How much do you want one of these
[inaudible] pipe that resembles a vagina?
It's height is adjustable.
While it's speed for,
since temperature can be very good time.
There you go.
Okay.
Sorry guys.
You're like slow it down.
How many of these you think this guy's gonna sell commercially?
That's what sells so well.
I would love to have one of these in the entryway.
I know.
Hi.
Come on in.
Yeah.
How you feeling?
You won't get your Dick off real quick.
So she and Tom wouldn't,
you didn't shoot it.
First bullet simulates a female organ.
This is so juvenile,
but it doesn't part of your brain still.
When you hear Asian languages spoken,
you're like,
how does that work?
Like he's just like,
he's like,
like,
it sounds just,
it's different.
It's definitely,
it's definitely different.
When I hear Asian guy speak in my head,
I still mock it and I go,
ah,
yeah,
no,
that's going to get remixed mix.
That's a new,
that's a new single.
You don't do it in your head when you're a kid.
When you made fun of Asian people,
you know,
because I,
I think I'm always waiting for like if I hear somebody speaking that usually
someone's going to translate or something.
So I'm waiting for what,
you know,
cause I,
I'm all juvenile.
When I heard him talk immediately,
I was mocking it.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't think,
I'm not thinking of mocking noises.
I just,
I usually just like hearing the noises because it sounds so different.
Sounds,
you know,
really interesting sounds all language has that thing right.
When you hear like Arabic and the hymen and you're like,
that's also that guy saying what time is the train?
Get here,
you know?
And it's all,
but then I'll mark that in my head too.
I'll be on the court.
Yeah.
I actually,
you know,
I guess mocking is all from perspective,
but I always kind of fuck with,
uh,
when I hear French,
when I hear some of them,
like that's,
yeah,
yeah.
That Shit my head.
Yeah.
I guess not mocked,
but like,
yeah,
when you kind of created in your head.
Yeah.
It,
yeah.
It's,
it's interesting.
There's interesting rhythms and tones,
you know,
to think about or I guess with,
since I don't speak any mandarin or Cantonese,
I just keep hearing
usually like three difference.
Yeah.
I'm one of them.
Like that's the whole thing.
Yeah.
No,
I was repeated and you know,
it's not really what he says cause that's not what he said.
I don't think exactly making fun of it though.
It's offensive.
I'm a little offended.
No you're not.
No,
I think it's like,
not really,
like he's making fun of it.
He's a,
he's like kind of,
you know,
just,
try to express the feeling a real thing.
Oh No.
One time I was showing apartments in Boston after college and I was showing them
to some Chinese students and like two of them were walking at my pace and then a
few were further behind.
So when we got to the door,
we look back and they're like a block behind it.
And so I asked him,
I go,
how do you say hurry up.
But like aggressively.
And they,
they gave me just a quick thing to say.
I don't remember what it was,
but it was like,
sure.
So I turned
and I screamed it at the top of my lungs.
And these Chinese if you like,
and they just ran as fast as they could that it was like learning a little
expression and other language to say to scream at somebody.
That's a thrill.
So this Dick Milking machine?
Yeah.
This is just for science.
Is that right?
This,
is this supposed to be an easier,
more convenient way to donate.
Donate.
Yeah.
So sexual intercourse by moving back and forth,
it's able to buy a huge extent.
Now I want to listen to his voice.
You could hear him more in,
what was it in this one?
See The 19 teens at this hospital come on.
Prove useful for you or logic.
It's funny that it goes in and out like that.
That just seems so like without a great deal of help because it's like,
even though it's going in and out like that,
I mean,
I begin to show a guy putting as well.
I hope so.
This looks like we're the mouth right now.
This guy's about to stick his dick in her mouth.
Oh Wow.
I hope he does it.
At least seeming says it's an efficient way to maximize the amount of weird that
it goes in and out like that because it almost seems like ineffective in a way.
Well it just seems like someone should,
it should happen internally kind of.
You know what I mean?
Exactly.
Yeah.
You know like cause that seems like someone would just move with it.
You know what I mean?
This way definitely this device is far more efficient than masturbation,
but there are still some,
for instance,
it can know exactly simulate the temperature and feel of a female organ,
no shit.
So the device may not fit as well when compared to human beings off the rule.
It is made out of plastic and metal and also when you know she keeps sucking and
then you keep shaking,
it can turn that knob that you got to turn that knob down.
Thanks for coming.
Brand has really nice is annually at $13,000 each.
Oh there you go.
Been bought by clinics and the USA,
Germany,
Russia and for any of them sucking machines right there.
That's I,
he's removing the stigma from sperm donation.
Do you think that's,
that's what heaven looks like to some people go in a room and there's a bunch of
them.
Yeah.
13 grand to get your dick second machine guys.
It's not that bad.
It's not bad.
The real girl,
the real dolls really are around 10 grand.
All the high end ones.
Huh?
I from what I've seen on some document or not the,
the $10 ones from big lots.
How much are they?
Like 10 grand and they're heavy.
They're really heavy.
Your Life.
Like you have a bus and one of those I had,
no,
I've never even seen one.
Really.
I,
I'm,
I want to see one though in person and I saw a documentary about him.
I know there's a lot of,
have you seen videos of people who show they're kind of like do video blogs
about their life living with real dolls and they treat them very much like real
people
and they have like relationships with the ice.
You probably saw,
you probably saw that in the documentary.
There's a lot of that online too,
just like on Youtube and stuff.
It's really fascinates me a lot actually.
It's really,
you know,
just that people have these really,
these like relationships and they,
they really care for these dolls.
It's all interesting.
And you know what,
I and I respect it and I approve it cause,
cause I do indeed.
Let's,
let's give people one last.
I'm a plug.
Everything like everything.
So yeah,
the CSOS special,
please check it out.
Yup.
Appealing to the mainstream.
It's on CSO.
You can watch you.
So on Amazon prime is an add on service and there's this,
this is gonna sound like a commercial,
but there's a seven day free trial.
And even if you don't use the trial,
it's only $4 a month.
But anyway,
there's a lot of other cool stuff on,
on CSO.
But anyway,
that's the special.
It's,
you know,
then,
uh,
you can check out,
that short film I made a few years ago called I don't dance.
And when your Vimeo,
Vimeo and,
uh,
go to vimeo.com/brent wine buck and there's other videos and stuff on
youtube.com/burn Leinbach there it is.
There it is.
All right.
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
there's all the info.
Check him out.
Absolutely hysterical dude.
And uh,
thanks for coming by today.
Thanks for having me.
It was really nice to see you guys.
You too brother.
All right,
here we go.
Closing Song.
We'll see you next week.
Thanks guys.
Okay.
Hi Jay.
Ray Media.
Gwen.
And you did that wrong.
I was single for a while,
but then I learned this miso soup recipe and the guys just started coming
around.
Check your pants in here.
Get your key is just block the town.
Oh,
you guys get down here.
Dope it every day.
What.